The joe rogan experience podcast is
brought to you by the flashlight.
If you're going to Joe Rogan dot cotton,
what does my website,
Joe rogan.net and click on the link for
the flashlight and enter in the code
named Rogan.
You will get 15% off the
number one sex toy from him.
We were also sponsored
by audible.com oops,
that's my laptop in the backdrop.
Whoopsies we're also sponsored
by onnit.com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
a cognitive enhancer and a new mood,
which is a five HTP supplement.
It has five HTP and it
also has l tryptofan.
So it has like sort of
a time release time.
It's like a,
it gives you the,
the effects a longer throughout the
day because El Tryptofan is one of the
building blocks of five HTP and Serotonin.
So it's a,
a great mood enhancing supplement.
I enjoy it.
And um,
as we say with all these things,
if you,
uh,
if you're inching into nootropics,
please go online,
research it,
look into it.
There's some interesting stuff.
Experiment with it.
If you think that you know our stuff
costs too much or you don't have the money
or whatever,
just it,
just steal the recipe,
steal the recipe,
go buy your own stuff in bulk and
try it out and I hope it works.
And if you want to buy it from us,
go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t.com.
If you enter in the code name Rogan,
you'll get 10% off that two son.
All right,
we've got a a serious man here today,
Ladies and gentlemen
for some serious talk.
But uh,
he may or may not have
smoked the devil's cabbage.
So we're going to have a good time.
Kick it,
Brian.
Where's the music?
Oh,
what'd you do?
What is this?
This is like a remote version of the song.
What's,
it doesn't go through the speaker.
I forgot that we got to
get a new computer folks.
We've got to get a new computer.
Are A,
we have only a few years old,
but try running a computer from four
years ago with today's operating systems
and all this stuff.
It's,
it's,
you noticed the difference.
You notice a big difference
in how fast it works,
especially when you're not
just like using iphoto.
Yeah.
I feel like for regular stuff it's almost
like they make things more complicated
so you actually need,
you know,
a bigger hard drive and a bigger,
a a faster processor.
But you know for like just web browsing
how much that's what most people do.
It's the most intensive thing.
Yeah.
I don't think many people are editing
podcasts and videos and this and this one.
This is the old,
what's the power?
Mac is what is,
what's it called?
That shit is like the noisiest
thing in the whole entire world.
It's like that's supposed to
be that top of the line thing,
but there's 17 fans on there and the
thing just sounds like it's going to take
on men for being in the room
with sensitive mics and podcasts.
It's meant for,
you know,
some serious work.
Yeah.
Our friend we have here today,
ladies and gentlemen,
is a serious author,
a man,
his name is Daniel Bolelli as I say it,
right?
Yup.
And he wrote a book about arts called a
on the warrior's path and also wrote
a book about religion called 50,
what is it,
the 50 things they don't want
to or not supposed to know.
Religion.
Yeah.
And you wrote it for disinformation.
So this Info Dotcom guys,
which I really,
I'm a fan of their stuff.
I love the,
uh,
the Europe being lied to books.
They're great,
really,
really awesome stuff.
And really like great toilet reading,
you know,
a feast.
The person who tells me that say,
yeah,
you know,
because you are being lied to.
It's like really short
paragraphs and you know,
you might,
if you're healthy you probably won't get
through a whole paragraph and a shit.
If you get through a whole
paragraph and his shit,
you might want to put some
Broccoli in your diet,
you know,
but they're,
they're,
they're good like short pieces.
Brian,
what the fuck?
What the fuck,
Brian?
I'd have no fucking fucking,
um,
but they're,
they're good short pieces that,
um,
they're,
you know,
they're really eye
opening and enlightening.
So the,
in disenfranchised,
they put out a lot of cool stuff.
And so they've gotten behind you.
I think they've put out some
of Graham Hancock stuff too,
didn't they?
Yeah,
that's what was kind of
like the Formula Ford.
His books don't like.
Their whole idea was,
I submit it to them,
this giant book I've been working
on 400 pages long with footnotes,
all this stuff about religion.
And they were like,
yeah,
that's sweet on the old,
but seriously,
can you give us something quick?
And that funny,
weird that has an impact
right away that people,
as you put it down the toilet and
get on something in dance back quick,
very difficult for people to discipline
themselves to read any serious piece of
work on anything.
It's just when you're just simply
stating the facts and documenting things,
it's,
you know,
it's oftentime a dry read.
Even though it's fascinating information.
They're really clever
in their idea of just,
you know,
figuring out a way to get it.
And then,
you know,
probably once people read this book,
get familiar with your writing,
get into,
then maybe they'll dive into like
some of your more serious stuff.
Right?
Yeah.
Even see it as a big large cause I had
even in the big book I add the one of the
chapters about the existence of God
beginning sweet though woman having a
screaming orgasm.
So I mean he's only,
it can only be socio Yosi right.
But I guess it was a,
the idea was not,
let's do something else that they
have a CD has going to 56 they are not
supposed to know it works well for them.
They want to do something or religion
and initially because I was attached to
the other project,
I was like ask her to wait.
I don't want to have to wait.
I want to,
when they told me the magic word advance,
suddenly I wasn't.
Yeah,
a little money always greases the wheels.
Like what do you want me to be weird
and funny and quick about religion?
No problem.
Now you,
where are you from?
Italy.
Yeah.
What part of Italy are from mainland,
which by the way,
I want to apologize to your list
in cause I've been living here,
believe it or not,
I've been living here 20 years
and when I first moved there,
I swear I was speaking
almost decent English,
but then somebody brought to my attention
that many American women like my weird
Italian access,
he kept it simple.
A good one to have.
Matt,
I'll tell you what.
If I talked like you,
I'd keep that shit too.
I can understand you.
I mean
it's not like you're not,
it's not difficult to
understand is you're very clear.
You just have a very
distinct Italian flavor.
It's like reading cursive writing.
Exactly like cursive,
like typing.
If you,
if you had a typing program
that type in cursive
being understood versus me like my women.
No,
I think I take me like,
yeah,
that sounds like a lot of fun.
Yeah.
Women,
well men do too,
man.
You hear girl than English accent.
You're like,
Ooh,
listen to that.
You know.
No Australian English,
anything.
Yeah.
You know,
it's why?
Why is that?
What is this?
Everyone's dissatisfied
with what they are.
Everyone is looking for
something different.
Everyone wishes they were someone else.
Everyone sees the grass
greener heavily goes,
God damn,
I wish I had an accident.
Like that guy.
Hey works for me.
So I'm just,
it's one of the biggest sins,
right?
When you fake an accent,
can there be more douchey thing to do?
Like remember when Madonna
was talking English?
Do you remember that Brian?
Yeah.
She only did it for like a little bit
until people start calling her on it.
Brittany,
Brittany Spears also data
for a while it seems like,
but Britain,
nobody takes Britney spears.
Seriously.
You know,
Britney spears is a crazy person.
Madonna.
It's like a legit artist.
He's got a little carried away.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people that do that.
Why actually trained some sentences.
Just kid.
I have caffeine for awhile
and fake accident for this
is my sixth or seventh day
of no caffeine.
Yeah,
that's fascinating man.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
I'm a junkie.
I didn't even know it was a junkie
feel great now,
but,
uh,
I'm not convinced that I'm
going to stay off the coffee,
you know,
it's just like,
I now I know what it's like to be
like person hooked on cigarettes,
a cigarette.
I'm like,
no,
he just coffee right now.
You're like,
oh,
that looks delicious.
No,
because the physical poles on the same,
um,
the physical pole and I can substitute it.
Like I'll drink like a chai tea latte,
which has like the tiniest
amount of caffeine.
Nothing like a coffee,
but it's like a warm liquid per day.
Don't main lineup.
I just take them right
into my fucking veins.
Um,
but uh,
do you drink coffee brother?
You had a really good point.
You were saying before
the podcast about this,
we were speaking about to use it the
same way as somebody who was used as hard
drugs,
you know,
dry.
I'll try just when I absolutely need it.
Then I'm wired for 10 hours.
I don't,
I'm not even going to getting coffee.
I'm just going to have a
double espresso when I need it.
Just go with you.
[inaudible]
speak 50 miles an hour for an hour and
then pass out and not actually for three
months.
That's the Harry.
Such a smart move.
That's such a smart move.
The reason why I did this and
the first was because I took,
I took a few days off just randomly,
just like I,
you know,
decided that just didn't want any coffee.
And then I had a cup of
coffee and Oh my God,
my heart was pounding and I was like,
wow,
this is crazy.
We just took a couple days,
maybe three days,
and I was,
you know,
my,
my tolerance had broken down.
Right?
I don't know why or how that happens
that quick or if I just got a really good
batch at Starbucks.
And then I started thinking about it like,
wow,
how much resources is my body using
to fight off the stimulant every day?
And how normal is this?
You know,
how healthy is this?
It can't be.
And I get the same feeling like when,
when I'm drinking coffee that I do when
I smoked too much cigarettes where it
feels like my body is like craving it.
But I get a headache kind of from it.
Like I could probably do it.
Right.
Yeah.
Poison.
And you're,
you're,
you're addicted,
you know?
Yeah.
Most certainly am addicted to coffee.
I see it and I smell it,
but I can get around it with
t and t doesn't wire me.
Doesn't work for me.
It doesn't ice tea.
I drink shit loads of ice tea.
But that is like as
bad as drinking coffee,
I think.
Really?
Yeah,
there's coffee,
but you know,
you could drink herbal tea too.
I like herbal tea.
You know,
you could have like,
you know,
there's,
there's a lot of different types of
herbal tea that have no caffeine in them.
For me it's like tape Pletcher
our buddy said it best.
She said it's like,
drink a cup of coffee.
It's like having a warm hug.
You know?
It's like,
I'm not really looking to
be wired from the coffee.
I just want some warm
liquid that tastes good.
I like the taste of coffee.
Yeah.
I think you need more love,
man.
I need more love.
I think you've got a good point,
brother.
I liked the way this guy thinks.
So you a,
you wrote this book on religion and
you wrote also a book on martial arts.
So what you and I,
I have a
lot in common man.
We have a lot of uh,
very,
uh,
similar interests.
Um,
w how did you get involved in religion?
Were you raised religious?
No.
Um,
no.
I just,
I'm fascinated by it because you
see how much he means to people.
I would match their whole
world view their life,
their priorities,
who they marry,
who they want to out with.
Everything depends on the kind of
stuff they put in their head based on
religions.
So it's powerful stuff.
It's amazing that it's still works.
This is a 2011.
It's,
it's,
you know,
with,
it's very difficult to have
pure objective thinking.
But then again,
you know,
the thing is the staff that dry.
So these is that people are scared of
dying and rightfully so because you know,
we don't go and throw object shape.
We don't know anything about
anything really about that.
I'm like,
you only verse works just died.
So we should say rest in
peace to Patrice O'Neil,
who's a great guy and a great
comedian and an awesome dude,
awesome thinker.
Cause a warm friendly guy.
Oh,
we'd love,
always love seeing that guy
and I'm going to miss him.
I miss him a lot.
It was a,
it was a great comedian who's a great guy,
you know,
just sucks.
It just,
he had poor health,
you know,
he had diabetes and uh,
yeah,
I guess he just didn't
really take care of himself.
He ate too much and he wound
up having a stroke and um,
then he was in a coma for
a little while I guess.
And then,
you know,
he was a,
it was really difficult
to get the information out
because the family was sort
of protecting it and rightly so.
We don't know exactly the details of it.
So,
uh,
this is all really what I'm repeating.
It's just stuff that I
heard on the Internet.
I have and I'm so sad about it.
I didn't want to call anybody
and talk to anybody about it.
You know,
I talked to Stan hope about it today.
We talked to for this deck.
It's a minute.
We can,
we can you say it sucks.
We both just said that we didn't,
we really didn't even say
anything other than a socks.
So I asked him,
I go,
did you hear about Patrice?
He goes,
yeah,
socks.
I go,
yeah.
Socks.
Can't even say anything else.
I'm,
what am I?
Anything else has,
is going to happen to all of us one day.
It's like the real moment of actually
dealing with loss is really intense.
You know,
it's,
it's real hard to deal with Patrice.
We're going to mess you,
miss you a lot,
man.
He was,
he's one of those comics
date that was so quick.
Like just seeing them on
opion Anthony all the time.
That was the one thing that I could just,
he who was really fast and hilarious,
like how powerful,
he's a comic man.
He's a real comic.
Did my favorite Patrice thing
wasn't even have him doing standup.
My favorite purchase thing was him on a,
um,
one of those like Fox rate.
It was either Fox News or one of those
talk shows where someone had said
something inappropriate
and gotten in trouble.
I believe it was like opie and Anthony,
they,
I think it was the incident where they
had some crackhead on their show and the
crack head,
which talked about he wanted a rape
Condoleezza Rice and like it was,
it was just,
they had a crazy person
on their show and like,
and they got suspended for it.
I think that was what he was defending.
But there was a woman on who was with
him and this woman was like talking about
how you shouldn't have said this,
you shouldn't have done that.
And Patrice has just clown her.
He's just like,
you don't understand funny.
You guys understand funny.
It all comes from the same place.
And the way he said it,
it was so honest and so well thought
out and it made them look so silly.
It made people criticizing people who
stepped across the line with comedy
criticizing them,
you know,
as if what they're comedy was.
It was like an actual statement
of their real beliefs.
Now it's comedy,
you know,
and it all comes from the same place
that the ability or the attempt rather to
try to make people laugh.
And he broke it down so well.
And it was so funny the way he did it,
the way he handled it was so brilliant.
He was just a real quick guy,
a real unique thinker and a guy who,
you know,
I always really love to see.
And whenever I ran into
him I was always happy.
You know,
comedians are a rare animal.
There's not that many of us.
It's just the video right here that,
that,
that you're talking about.
Um,
I don't think so.
No,
it was,
yeah,
that's it.
Yeah,
absolutely.
[inaudible]
clown,
this lady,
oh,
sorry.
She took part in the recent protests
calling for radio stations to shop,
stop supporting negative language in
music and talk radio and also our favorite
standup comic.
Patrice O'neil.
Patrice are ONA next.
Oh,
nice.
I hope Davey.
I was Jamie and I was then Lucy job.
Well,
Imus.
It's funny,
this is thing I have.
I don't know her,
but I'm uh,
I'm assuming that she has
nothing to do with funny.
So I'm gonna speak as the expert on funny,
funny.
People should just be
left to try to be funny,
but it would,
if they're not funny,
then you made a mistake.
But how many,
listen,
how many times has the unfunny,
how many unfunny rape jokes lead to rape?
Like,
I don't know how many
jokes about rape there are.
There's a lot,
but you're not funny.
You're world is to Mexico.
Next one.
The big story.
My world is people trying to be funny.
You think it's okay to try
to make jokes about rape?
I'm diabetic.
I make fun of that.
I'm a victim.
I might lose a toe to make funny.
I'm trying to make fun of anything.
I,
I think I can make fun of Sonia.
You know what's happening now.
It's the marketplace.
Okay.
Is deciding what's appropriate
and what's not appropriate.
I think the nation is just tired.
There's a new mood in the nation,
the nation.
You know what?
We're tired of things that are just,
the nation is painful.
And you mom,
I'm not the nation.
I'm just speaking for me and sunny.
You're speaking for the
nation or you speak it for,
yeah.
You know why?
Because I remember six years ago doing
something against Anthony opening because
they were just so outrageous and they're
violent images to the neighborhood out
to women was just uncalled for.
And now,
now I think people don't try to be funny.
I think now people in this
country trying to be higher.
You know what?
I don't care if they
were trying to be funny.
That's what I'm saying.
And tell you in that business,
I've been into your show once and
it wasn't very funny being a woman
like me.
I was in the paper with her
and the joke is hilarious.
Called the angry pirate.
And The lady who wrote it in the,
in her outrage didn't
even know what it meant.
And anybody who read it laugh
cause they know what funny.
You're not living in the context of funny.
You'll get all these guns have every
right to be as funny as they want.
They can go out and try to
be as funny as they want.
Make as much money,
make as much money being
as funny as they want.
This is what's happening.
There is a change in this country.
People are realizing they
have an opportunity to speak
out and advertise their
listening.
You're not going to get
paid as much money anymore.
That's what it is.
The marketplace,
they'd been on a tear lately.
Are they cleaning house or is
this the PC cops run a month.
You know what it is,
John.
You know what it is?
Why you reading that paper
is the PC cops run a mug?
Of course she is.
She's,
she has an entire encyclopedia
of her stance on it,
but it's no passion involved.
It's not a real,
this is just what she has to say.
We are outraged and fired.
He's an insightful main calling.
I'm outraged.
I am.
You know what?
These people in this country,
here's what,
here's my question.
How can you justify a bad joke?
A joke that isn't funny.
Oh wait,
wait,
wait.
Go ahead and attempt it.
That isn't funny.
Doesn't get any laughs
and is about raping a,
the first black woman to ever becomes a
secretary of state in the United States.
Throw that at me
trying to fight for the joke.
May or may funny jokes and unfunny jokes,
uh,
come of the same birth date.
You,
you don't know if anything
is going to be funny.
You should attend to be
able to make anything funny.
Think a joke about rape is
doomed to be not fun as possible,
but I've heard him,
you heard the funny rape joke.
I say a couple of watch my feel special.
Pretty good
that if you're having sex with a woman,
oh,
doggie style.
And if you
just the right,
it's a Jackie late and I and kick her in
the Shin as she walks around like urgh.
It's the angry pyre.
That's what she was trying to say.
Hitting her in the back of her head.
Her body don't be punched,
which will then why are you laughing?
It's called humor that she has no one.
And the same problem that opie and
Anthony that you can't say anything on the
hair to say anything you want.
It might not be funny.
You might get in trouble for it,
but you should be able to be attempted.
And plus when is a crazy,
but I'm going to get an
opportunity to rate the president,
the president's wife,
John,
trying to be funny.
All right,
Patrice,
why aren't I hearing now Sharpton
complain about this thing involving,
cause it wasn't involving a young uh,
black women.
Whoa.
This evolving in a very
prominent black woman.
Well where was she throwing
during young black?
Everybody has their agenda
because there I was there.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
right.
Excuse me.
Know Why am I not here?
Cause it doesn't concern him.
It's not concerned him as black is,
you know it.
Come on now you know what Al had,
Al Sharpton has his agenda and it was
perfect for al young black women and now
she's representing just women in general.
She's not representing the nappy hope.
Ah,
she's representing just the whole
and that she has nothing to do.
Just the whole
tone.
You know what?
Women have been abused publicly in the
media for too long and people are tired
of it.
This has been a beautiful response
of just the general public saying to
advertisers,
where your consumers,
she's awesome.
Want to have to avoid
everything in the street.
We don't want to have to worry about what
radio station we turn on and there is
some really derogatory violent,
you're going to get to
deal with information.
Um,
Ma'am is second hand from someone making
you aware that someone may have said
something that you should be upset about?
It's a shame y'all could
stitch a sweet deal.
The people you represent on all victims.
Theresa,
Neil,
thank you very much.
Thanks for both of you.
We appreciate
the time for big love like dumb people
who talk ridiculous and try to sound
intelligent.
I think she's like,
it was speaking for the entire country.
We and we are fed up and we're like,
whoa,
whoa.
How preposterous.
How beautiful.
Was he in that though?
Yeah,
it was.
It was beautiful.
I love that dude.
He is who?
Messy Buddy.
That's it.
Rest in peace.
See Ya on the other side.
Peace out.
Alright Daniel,
back to you brother.
Yup.
Um,
so Danielle,
how'd he say it?
Danielle.
Slick bastard.
I love the fact that
you admitted he kept it.
He kept that accent.
That's fantastic.
So,
um,
I don't know how we got into this,
about people being afraid to die.
That's what it was.
And then uh,
yeah cause I mean wait through legion.
If you read even like early 99
that it's people are sinking.
Okay.
Now we modernity,
you are in a mother and
ward and more secular word.
Oh the kind of more
traditional superstitions are
all going to phase out and
immediately makes sense on the surface.
But not really because until you have the
answers to the things that make people
really freak out.
Dying.
Grief,
what the hell?
You know,
cause I mean,
our life is so short and we don't know
Jack Shit about before her afternoon
until you give some people some answers.
People are not comfortable
having no answers,
no matter how bullshit
does answers are they,
they need them.
It's almost like religion is some sort
of an evolutionary device like a bridge
to to take us from being monkeys
to being enlightened beings.
Like we need some horse
shit to get us through this.
We need a believe.
Otherwise.
You know,
the idea of no one ever wants to think of,
you know,
the,
the concept of life being that it may
be that you have lived this exact life
before and you will live it over and
over again until you get it right.
And the idea that this
could go on into infinity,
you know,
and that might be what life really is.
And we,
we don't think of it as being possible
because it's too hard for our minds to
wrap around and too alien to
what we absolutely know to exist.
Like,
you know,
birth and death and you know,
having a certain amount of time here to
get things done and seeing people die,
you know?
But the actual possibility is almost like,
it's too fucked up for us.
So somebody had to invent religion in
order to just patch up the road till we
make it there.
Yeah.
Cause I mean in reality
we don't really control,
you match anything your life and we're
conscious and where cultures are.
So that's a quagmire.
The universe,
the universe itself.
You know,
I had a bit and one of my past alums about
if you ever are starting to take your
life seriously,
just stand out and go outside and just
look up at space and just really wrap
your head.
I mean everybody looks at,
Oh there's a stars,
stars are bright tonight.
But very few people
actually look up and go,
wow,
you know that that literally is infinity.
Like we're floating and infinity.
And it's the majority of what I see,
you know,
all around the top.
It's easier to see infinity
than it is to see the ground.
I mean I have more view of the infinity
like and it's amazing how rarely that
comes up that no one,
no one talks about it.
And it almost,
it's too much.
So we just sort of accept that we live
in space and except that we look at the
clouds.
What is the first religion?
What's the first known religion?
I mean if you look at the,
I have a chapter in there that I had
half of the fun of doing this book was
coming up with a title schools in
like in a few words you just throw out
something outrageous and where that
gets things going and let me see if I
remember what this one exact was because
I had a blast with the origins of
religion.
Let me
when will this book we
released should be these week?
This week I think is [inaudible]
dot com you can pick it up
and then Amazon,
Amazon,
the whole,
Oh yeah,
this one.
I have a chapter entitled mammoth
porn and the Caveman see pulp.
The origins of religion,
because the very first evidence that
archaeology suggest these may be the
beginning of religious behavior.
They see these cave paintings laugh by
cave man were the main things that these
guys who are drawing where hunting
scenes and animals having sex,
the idea of being these guys who are like
doing these rituals because their life
was on the line to ensure success
in the hand and then you know,
animals are data so you need to make
sure there are more for the next time
around.
So you're trying to send out the
vibes of the animals have sex,
there's more of them and so on.
And what they would do it,
again,
this is pure speculation
because it would have,
how knows,
but it's a fan speculation
archeologist suggest that a,
they would have these rituals in front
of this painting where they mimic Hanton
and then they would mimic,
you know,
caveman and cave woman every
grindy sweaty dance scene,
semi sacks,
kind of like modern hip hop kind of thing.
And that would be the beginning of at
Allegion because they are trying to
influence the universe so that the
animals have more sex and there's more of
them to come along the next time.
Wow.
They thought it could be
thought of bullshit cause I
mean I would the you're not
really an archeologist basing it on
three pieces of information left 15,000
years ago.
But it sounds fun
and we,
we should clarify that you actually
know what you're talking about.
Unlike most of the time
that these discussions get
brought up on this podcast.
You're actually a professor you teach.
Where do you teach at?
I teach at Santa Monica
College and Cal State language.
And uh,
what is your education?
I started out,
when I came here I did a,
I did my ba in anthropology but then
I hated it and then I did the Nma in
American Indian studies
of all sayings and uh,
I need a second.
The main he story and I really,
I mean bottom line is there was mandatory
military service in Italy and you
could be fair eighth
as long as you wearing
cool.
So I was like,
I'll do another masters.
No problem.
I just,
we'll do the Indian studies
wants to be an interesting,
that's fun.
It was.
Or what the fuck.
I got really into American Indian
history a few years back and I read a,
a quite a few books on it.
It's an amazing case of genocide.
I mean,
people really can't even wrap their head
around how many American Indians died.
90% of our whole
population of wipe it out.
And that's how it's horrific,
horrific stories.
You know,
I read some soldiers of counts of what
they did to American Indians and uh,
it's uh,
it's horrific.
You know,
it got really terrifying
like serial killer stuff.
You know what they would do,
just heartless Ruth,
like the,
they treated them like they were not,
not even vermin,
you know,
a lot of
that is actually tied to religion
because the first way to um,
kind of dehumanizing
somebody is what I mean,
we throw the Western religions,
they have this division
between God and the devil.
Absolute good and absolute
from heaven and hell.
So there are the good guys are follow
God and then there's everybody else.
Cause,
I mean if there's only one right way,
then the idea is anybody who doesn't
follow hours by default is on the wrong
side.
And if you think of that a
couple of steps for it or done,
then that's what it leads to.
You know,
in the idea of you guys are the servants
of the day while they are not really
human anyway,
this low 30 new left and right
is it's an act of justice as the,
that's why I don't mind.
I use these in class all the
time cause I have a blast.
Uh,
everybody,
even if they never read any of this stuff,
I've heard about the whole uh,
story about Moses and the
10 commandments and so on.
Then after that I ask my students about
what happens right after that story.
Cause that's where it gets
juicy and they're like,
ah,
I don't know.
Something,
it wasn't golden calf or some crap.
Like the,
some of the Jews are not
worshiping the one God.
I'm like,
yeah,
that's right.
And what does Moses do about it?
Right after getting the 10 Commandments?
I Dunno.
Like he gathers,
there's a,
the law,
your list,
you know the streak,
monotheistic people who
are still on his side.
He tell them,
hey guys,
you know,
those are our friends.
They're our neighbors.
Some of them are family,
but they're worshiping other gods.
We can't have that.
So you know what to do,
get your weapons.
Let's go from one side to the camp
of the either and killed them all.
And so right after the 10 commandments,
you have a nice story of
some 3000 Jewish tribes.
Then being hacked to that
by the monotheistic Jews
against the polities stick.
Joe's,
Jesus Christ.
But I lead those mass
sucker right off the bat.
Wow.
They are like Moses or nope.
That is ridiculous.
That's why.
That's amazing.
It's amazing.
And this is the Old Testament,
the old testament.
So freaky.
The Old Testament is
just filled with freaky.
It's like one of the most
psychedelic bizarre books.
You know,
the,
just all the stories.
It just genesis and it's so
much in there that's like,
wait a minute,
what?
There was a fucking talking snake like,
come on man.
The devil appeared as a talking snake
and talked him into eating a fruit.
It was just a piece of fruit.
That's all they had to do.
Just a piece of fruit.
That's hilarious.
You know that God is just,
he's rules are soft.
Fucking serious.
You eat my fucking apples,
bitch.
I'm not just going to punish you.
I'm going to punish every fucking
person from now till eternity.
As long as their people,
the people are fucked
because one dumb bitch,
eight an APP.
It's my fucking apple.
That amazing.
You don't understand.
Funny.
I'm afraid you got your mellow out.
Should God,
what the fuck man?
God,
you need to smoke a joint and
use some of your own creation.
It's amazing how ruthless the the
like when you go back in history,
how ruthless God's war.
Absolutely.
No,
that's why if it cracks me up when you,
we like could he Stanford,
the
mantle is complaining about Hollywood,
about all the sex and violence
because if you look at the Bible,
there's,
I mean it's awesome.
There's more sex and violence seemed
to Bible than any Hollywood movie I can
think of.
You know,
he gets so insanely graphic
that is like Dame really,
this is what,
yeah,
it's amazing too.
How many of the stories are like really
similar to all older stories from other
religions?
You know,
like the one,
the one that always got me was the epic
of Gilgamesh and the story of Noah Arc,
they're so similar and it's like,
it's like really,
it's like,
I wonder what really
happened and my speculations,
totally speculation as there probably
was some sort of a great catastrophe a
long time ago.
But of course in every
giant tsunami or flood,
it's not everyone that dies.
Some people are going to live
and the people that live,
they're going to have to have some
story for how they lived and you know,
a couple of generations in when
everybody's still live in like a monkey,
you know,
running around collecting fruit,
trying to get their goats to fuck
so they can kill them and eat them,
you know,
and just wondering how they got,
why we seem really intelligent.
How did we get to this shitty point?
Like w how can we now you fucks and
figured out tools or clothing or houses or
anything yet.
Well,
a long time ago Noah was the only person
and we are the child children of Noah.
It doesn't even take into
account that you know how many,
how many people were with Noah?
Everybody came from Noah.
We're wears black people come from,
what about Chinese people?
Yeah.
How's that happen?
How long does it take before,
I mean Noah only supposedly it
was a couple thousand years ago.
Right?
What was that 3000 years ago
or something like that though.
You have like 6 billion people.
It was that possible that says luck
is that this is the dumbest shit ever,
but it's probably the original
story was probably an actual event.
Like I think most of those,
those depictions were actual events.
It just got distorted.
You know the,
the,
the telephone game.
Like you tell a friend and he tells a
friend or was it called top operator?
Yeah.
I mean by the time you get
to the last person and this,
you know,
that's actually finding out your butt and
get up because he's one of the ways in
which I can got a sources.
So when we talk about religion
in class and I bring gap,
when I speak off the Bible,
I tell them,
you know,
how do you come out?
How do you know that
this is the real stuff?
And I tell them,
you know,
really we have been talking about an
oral traditions for generations before
anybody write them down
and they saw asking him,
have you guys ever played
over eight 30 or nine?
Do you know how that works?
And then you ended up so picture play,
operate there for maybe 50
hours and then you had a cord,
all the answers.
And then 200 years later somebody come
around and look at the answer and decide
which ones are true
and which ones are not.
And that's the word of God for you.
Yeah.
Like wow.
Tried to ciphering that.
Then people will fight
to the death over those,
those beliefs.
Lethal call map with theater or Dara to
change the meaning that's I need to cut
off your bolts and board.
Well,
I bought the fact that,
you know,
like even the shit that was written
down when they wrote it down in ancient
Hebrew,
ancient Hebrew is a very bizarre
language and it doesn't have,
they don't have numbers.
So letters double as numbers.
So there's a numerical meaning to words.
There's a different grasp to the words
that we can really barely comprehend.
And these words [inaudible]
numerical content was very important.
Uh,
for the actual meaning like
the word God and the word love.
They have the same numerical
content and there was,
uh,
you know,
a translation from that too raw to,
to Latin and then to Greek.
And if they're doing that,
I mean,
Jesus Christ.
What w what are they?
Gonna I mean,
how do you even know what the
fuck was the original word?
Oh yeah,
exactly.
On the telephone.
After you played for the long and somebody
decided then you'll translate it in a
bunch of languages and that it's like,
no,
there are so many few
authors to go through it.
I woulda hell knows what
it was at the beginning.
And people have to make decisions,
you know,
like they have to decide like
what goes in and what goes out.
You know,
how to like the King James
version and you know,
the,
the whole idea behind the new
testament is just so preposterous.
If you find out how it was created,
it was Constantine a bunch of bishops,
right?
I mean constantly was against their
best Calico's it's just about,
you know,
where's Nadine enemies and he's the guy
who pushed out or I need those that are
formed that,
but increased the idea is why.
And he's like,
I don't know.
That's the guy you want to
have in your car and therefore,
yeah,
that's the guy that's creating the Bible.
You could fucking crazy.
It's amazing because you know,
people will say,
if you bring up the Bible would
bring up crazy stuff that oh,
that's the old testament.
We go by the New Testament that the
new testament was written by a fucking
murderer.
Even that is bullshit because it's,
they only say that about the old
testament when the old testament is solved
Zilliow Virta topknots
that it's embarrassing.
Then anytime it say something that
they want it and that's not in the New
Testament,
he's like,
hey,
it's in the Bible,
but I'm like,
no,
wait,
that's the book you just told
me that he doesn't count.
No,
but when he'd say something,
he law.
I like Danny counts.
How do you deal with that as you know,
as,
uh,
when,
when you're trying to,
when people are teaching it
and when you're trying to,
you know,
studied theology.
How do you mean?
How does anybody go?
Why?
I mean it's,
it's how many people who were actually
studying theology are religious and how
many of them get to a point
where they become agnostic?
Eh,
it's,
I guess it depends where they do it.
You know,
if they do it as some
hardcore Christian school,
well that's going to be
one type of clientele.
If they do it more in public schools.
When I first started teaching
the history of 30 John's class,
I thought,
shit,
why did I get myself into,
you know,
I'm gonna I was all excited until five
minutes before and then I'm like they are
going to kill me.
You know what I'm going to worry about
that like with like Muslims are like the
most is that the people reaction,
that stuff arrow that id open minded.
Otherwise they wouldn't be taking it
because they don't want to eat it.
Right.
So most of the people who do show up
are the ones who have a more minded
approach
and so on.
So they are cool,
you know they,
there are people to order,
we lean to chat and engage and so on.
If you,
if you have a mind and if you can
think and you start studying religion,
it's almost impossible to not be agnostic.
I mean
rarely stickily again nobody knows shit
wanting some kind of absolute answer
where there is none.
It's just showed that you are so damn
fearful that you just want to ignore any
evidence in order to decide the,
I need some serotonin.
It's also very weird characteristic that
people have to need closure and to need
a side to be on,
even though there's no answer yet.
We haven't reached that point yet.
There's,
there's a door you have to
open that door is death.
When that door opens,
you'll get some more information.
But who knows?
You might not be,
maybe not,
it might just be a baby in
1950 [inaudible] you know,
to say it is like,
you know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No,
look,
it's bizarre enough that you're a person
bizarre enough to use your eyeballs to
judge distance.
You have these fucking organs inside
your skull that measure light,
right and distance and
they figure out exactly,
precisely how far away you are from things
and that allows you to get into metal
boxes with rubber wheels.
And that's just as bizarre as coming
back as a baby in the fifties you know,
everything we do is bizarre.
No,
you've had the university's amazing.
I mean,
it's so weird
that it's beyond anything I can understand
and precisely because I respect it
and I may know of it.
Trying to make it all feet
in my little box of bow.
Every sing is supposed
to work is bullshit.
The best quote ever heard of
it from JBS Haldane who said,
not only is the universe queer than you
suppose it's queer than you can suppose
I can sign up for that.
Yeah.
Get it right.
Yep.
That's it.
So fucking what is,
what the fuck is that ridiculous.
So when you got involved in religion,
did you originally get involved with it?
Because from an archeological standpoint,
no,
it was a,
it was like God,
I got the involved with just
about every saint gods completely.
By chance.
I mean,
I wasn't willing to wait.
That would that add to for myself,
I would read mainly a lot of eastern
philosophy and stuff like that that I was
into.
But I would read for the hell of it.
And the,
um,
somebody down,
when they ask me,
hey man,
we need somebody to teach this thing,
can you do it?
I'm like,
no,
not really.
And they were like,
no,
come on,
you're kind of thing around.
I said this man,
you know,
a lot of chefs do it.
I'm like,
okay,
sure.
And I jump on and I'm like,
yeah,
I love this stuff.
This is fun.
I got to talk about all the
stuff I like and this is awesome.
And so then I started
reading more and more and uh,
but I mean,
yeah,
I mean,
I read my stuff before it will begin.
Wait,
they didn't know in their
moment of pure perversion,
I decided to read the entire Bible cover
to cover when I was 18 the most painful
experiences of my life.
But that's what got me up though.
When I got to this part,
uh,
the song of Solomon,
there's,
be able to have that book ended
up in the Bible is awesome.
It's like one of the best things,
all of a sad.
Then you have 10,
15,
I forgot how many pages where
they don't mention God ones,
they don't mention police,
they don't mention anything.
It jazz,
the super passionate,
erotic love poem between
a man and a woman.
A woman we enjoy sex as well
is also from our point of view,
which is completely unheard
of in the rest of the Bible.
And he's just the celebration
of sacs essentially.
And they just like,
I always like how the hell it is.
And that been very or no.
And my theory is that one of the guys
who are copying all the scriptures got
drunk one night and took the wrong scroll
and got this homemade power and area
by mistake.
It's awesome.
You know,
it's uh,
sum is it,
do you know of a John
Marco OLED gross work?
I heard of him.
Um,
I heard of him a bunch,
but I haven't read him actually directly.
He's the guy that was one of the,
um,
the people that was working on the Dead
Sea Scrolls who's working on deciphering
it.
And uh,
he was the only agnostic of the group.
And he wrote a book called,
we wrote a couple of them.
One of them was called the Dead
Sea Scrolls and the Christian myth.
And the first one was called the
sacred mushroom and the cross.
And that one's fascinating book.
It's a,
he believes that the entire works of
the Christian religion were originally,
um,
mushroom.
It was about mushroom eating and,
um,
psychedelic drugs and,
ritual sex and about a fertility rituals
and making sure that they kept breeding
and that,
you know,
women kept having babies,
shit that was seeing swale wrong.
Isn't that amazing?
That's,
and he said his,
he tracks down the word mushroom
or the word Jesus rather to a,
a,
an ancient Sumerian word.
The roots of it being an ancient Sumerian
word that means a mushroom covered in
God's semen.
And that the idea he believes,
and this is,
I mean he's making a big reach that I
don't think unless you have some sort of
serious education and language history,
you could totally even grasp the argument.
But what he's saying is that what
they used to call a mushrooms,
they,
it was,
it was like a,
God would come on the earth when it would
rain and then mushrooms would grow out
of that.
They would eat them,
they'd have these incredible
psychedelic experiences because of that.
And so that was Christ.
So Christ was a mushroom that
was covered in God seaman.
Well,
I mean,
you have stopped.
You ever ready?
Just thrown in the water?
Where's anything from [inaudible] to high?
You ask our to a lot of
psychedelic substances.
I'm Anita Muskata,
the mushroom itself,
a bunch of scenes that have been central
to people's religion because they open
up all these words and so on.
So,
so
probably the early origins of a lot of
the stores and a lot of the experiences
and no wonder you start seeing,
and we are dubbed,
God's flying around,
especially back when it
was hard to get food.
Oh yeah.
And it was difficult when people were
hunter gatherers essentially before
religion was written down,
people were,
I mean,
when they were supposed to be a
hunter gathers up until like what,
10,000 years ago,
10,000 years,
something like that.
Although that's coming into dispute,
you know,
they found a fucking fishing hooks and
fishing line and tuna bones tuna from
40,000 years ago and they don't know.
They don't,
they've never thought that people
were capable of doing this.
Now they're thinking that up to 40,000
years ago people were getting in boats
and they were going hundreds of miles
into the ocean and they were catching
tuna.
Dude tune up 40,000 years ago they were
in boats catching tuna like they have no
idea that that people were doing that.
This was,
this is a complete like a new revelation.
It's like going to rewrite
history because they,
I mean what kind of fishing line do you
have that you're making 42,000 years ago
that you can pull a fucking thousand pound
tuna out of hundreds of feet of water
and you've got to hook in some meat.
What is going on man?
How was that possible?
We might have to like re wire
the or rewrite the whole.
I've been,
I have a a very strong feeling that over
the next few years there's going to be
more and more evidence like this that
makes people want to push back the origins
of,
you heard it go back to the Tempe.
This,
this new structure that they found in
Turkey is another one where they're,
they're,
they're thinking they're going
to have to push back the,
uh,
the origins of civilization because
it's at least 12,000 years old and it's
these huge like sculpted stone columns
and they have all these animals that are
drawn on it that don't
even exist where you know,
in,
in Turkey.
So these animals like weren't
even supposed to be in the
fossil record from that
back then.
So what the belief is there,
the,
the current there,
where they're trying to say now is that
this was made by hunter and gatherers
and a lot of people going,
come on man.
Like what the fuck is this?
This is giant.
Did just the fact that someone
made something like this
13,000 years ago when we
never thought people were
making stuff like this.
You might have to go,
wait a minute,
how much of this is really a leftover?
Is there a bunch of stuff
we haven't found yet?
And if there is and we do
find it eventually there's
going to be a point in time
where they're going to have to say,
I think we've been around
longer than we think.
Not thought that and goes back
to the we don't know shit.
Right.
Yeah.
That's why we are rewriting history all
the time because I mean that's why you
know you read the history books and you
have like the last 50 years sees the
steak and then the first
20,000 years he's like,
okay,
we already here for a while and then 50
or so ago these App Ben and he's like,
okay,
we don't know much.
We also,
we look so much different
than anything else here.
You know we are,
we are some kind of an ape,
but God damn,
we looked different than
the rest of the apes.
How long did this take?
How long did it take for
us to look like this?
You know,
for east.
Sure.
Are you sure it's been a million years
is maybe he's been to and if it's been
too,
that changes a lot of shit.
You know,
we don't really know.
This is,
this is a lot of guessing going on man.
And how many,
I mean did,
did,
was it a clean separation
between us and the apes?
No.
Or maybe that hates to little cough,
but if there's something
that was super advanced,
more advanced than us,
we just haven't met it yet.
Right.
And it's here just hiding from us.
Like,
oh,
those crazy monkeys there.
It's just,
you know,
it's another couple
thousand years ahead of us.
Maybe that's what the aliens are
probably not.
Right.
So,
um,
this Marco Allegro guy
met a lot of controversy.
When was trying
to propose that religion might,
might've had its roots in
psychedelic experiences.
Why do you think people are so
reluctant to take in that possibility?
Cause anything,
any kind of psychedelic
experience is very individual.
You know,
it's hard to build that church on it in
a sense that it's hard to have a dogma
because it changes so much from
one experience to the next,
from one person to the next.
And people bottom line loft dogma,
that's the thing.
Direct short them direct experience
doesn't reassure them because they have to
base it on their own feelings of
their own in state on their own.
And it's too scary for people.
And now you,
we are you.
We are people.
It took so much shit
about why we like freedom.
Most people are terrified,
afraid of math.
People hate freedom.
You know they liked the idea of being
free but they ran to their chains anytime
they can because they need
something to keep them safe,
to make them feel like hey are okay,
we are going to be fine.
You know?
So I mean any direct experience,
I mean think about martial arts,
how long it took for people.
Super attached to these
is how we do things.
This is the throat of combat.
When in martial arts you can try it.
You know,
he's not like a religion where
there's not as much direct evidence.
You know,
you can try it and still people would
stick their head in the sand and no one
has seats.
That's some shit just didn't work.
And it was fascinating that it's
one of the most fundamental forms of
competition.
And yet we're way better at it now.
And we have evolved it now
over the last 20 years,
more than at any time in human history,
episode two.
So you got to think people should
have known a long time ago,
but not really.
Right?
Because fighting is difficult and it's,
it's dangerous and it's scary.
And most people try to avoid
it if and whenever possible.
So there's not a lot of testing it out.
Right.
And it wasn't until something like the
ultimate fighting championship came along
and we really found out
what actually works.
Now we know what fighting is.
Now we really know what fighting is.
That's amazing when you think about it,
just as an archeological thing,
you know,
the fact that over the last
20 years they figured it out.
Yeah.
No,
it's amazing.
It's amazing.
Even though the other day I thought
that I agree with what you said,
but I just saw the scene
that cracked me up.
I saw this Roman sculpture
a few days ago for,
I mean a picture where DERs,
these,
uh,
the naked guys wrestling.
No,
not even.
There's like these half man,
half horse.
Howard was called an English sense and
Tara was putting some dude in a heel
hook.
What's a minute tar and went to
Sentara is the one with the bull.
The center is the reform
force and that's my favorite.
The center hasn't there is and that guy
is put in the heel hook onto somebody.
Oh really?
He'll hook by a cent or 2000 years ago.
That's how they knew a lot of
submissions that back then.
I bet they had a couple of
them are sub 30 cool sakes.
But no,
I agree with you.
I mean the evolution over the last 20
years is unparalleled the way tiny singles
before.
That's why my dream would be to be able
to have the UFC offered allegiance where
that I learned at these people going
off about these lamb is awesome.
No,
you're a soccer boot.
These of is going to to like
just shut up and get in a cage.
I sit back have a BRC.
What that said that we
could stop whining forever,
accepts it losses though.
Not Bad.
They always think
the guy got lucky and they
want to come back and you know,
Islam is going to make a comeback bitch.
But wouldn't that be fun?
That'd be awesome.
Well,
it's very strange to me when
guys switched religions like,
you know,
like a dude will convert and become,
a Jew or you know,
convert and become something else or a
Christian or Catholic base it on walk
more evidence.
They found a better group of
people to hang out with think,
you know,
it's what it is.
It's like when you change nationalities.
Yeah.
You know,
it's uh,
it's,
it's a very controversial thing,
you know,
when you become a US citizen or you know,
when did you become a Unisis?
Yeah,
yeah.
Was that a weird thing for you?
I mean,
for one,
it didn't have to give
up Italian citizenship,
so it really doesn't change much.
I can still travel.
I can see that was bad ass
dual citizenships cool.
The way I didn't have these,
we are like,
Oh shit,
I'm Kathy,
my cat in the bridges with the best.
That's so I didn't have to do with that.
So it wasn't a weird,
you know,
it's just like ass stupid piece of paper
that I can go in line faster next time.
I've got a friend of mine who's got
that Canadian American dual citizenship
thing.
That's dope.
He goes back and forth with no problems.
You can work over there
and work over here.
It's a cool,
beautiful.
Yup,
Yup.
Lots of very good gig.
But when you signed up to the evil empire,
when you signed up the final documents,
we were like,
oh my goodness,
look what I've just joined up with.
I just joined up with the baddest gang
and human history and that's really what
he joined.
He joined the United States.
I always say that the people in the United
States that we are living inside the
balls of the Dick.
That's fucking the world.
I like Gary mentioned mentoring play it,
but we don't,
we're not a part of it,
but we,
we essentially take residents inside the
balls of the Great Dick that's fucking
the world hundred different military
bases in a hundred different countries or
whatever the fuck we've got now.
I love to write that down.
That's awesome.
That's what it is.
You know,
you just joined the best Bot.
This is the best bot.
It's safe here.
Mad.
We're just throwing a lot of punches.
Everybody's back in the fuck up.
We've got this thing circled
everywhere else is quite dangerous.
So,
um,
you,
you got into this religion,
you started teaching
and you wrote this book.
Now in,
in writing this book,
was there anything that you,
you
found that you found the shocked,
even you with all the shit
that you know about religion?
No.
I mean I've seen enough
stuff that I buy now.
It's kind of hard about bringing the
arguments with fundamentalist people.
No,
because I think one of the
scene I tell them is that,
amen.
I'm not telling you anything about any
single one religion because we teen any
religion,
there's so much variation that DDS
agree on just about every sing among
Christians among Muslims.
I'm like,
I'm just making a general point about
where assert dine belief has led to do it.
You want to identify with that.
Good for you.
You don't,
but I'm not saying you're
already John Equal this.
I'm saying that as busy as
the contents of your religion,
but my low out of cause
they don't take it.
That's personnel.
And then I tried to make it kind of
fun and just play and laugh about it.
So having a sense of humor,
usually metal of the mouth Alito,
so it doesn't get too,
I've even had some hardcore
weird fundamentals that I sold.
They were out to kill me that
suddenly loved me by the end
of class and I'm like,
really?
Have you been listening to I?
That's where I think the
Italian accent coming in.
I don't think they
understood a thing guy said,
but it sounded cool.
And so they were smooth talker and
you obviously are well educated.
So the words come out nice and dry and
you know you're basically talking about
the Bible and their little brains lock up.
That is a problem too,
isn't it a problem?
There's some people are just dumb.
Yup.
I mean I'm afraid that's the majority
of people and I don't think it's,
I think a lot of people don't want to
believe that it's a biological issue.
A lot of people want to believe that it's
an education issue or an environmental
issue or cultural issue.
And they may be,
but it also might be,
it might be biological,
it might be,
look,
there's people that are born
and they're seven feet tall,
you know,
there's people that are born,
they have giant Dicks,
there's the,
you know,
there's a great variation of human beings.
And when I just see this
just giant wave of sloth,
you know,
you see like a giant percentage
of people in this country,
I don't know if it's 20% want
to know what the number is.
We just look at them.
You're like,
my God.
You're like barely thinking.
You're barely a person.
Like are you just lazy or do you have
like a nine volt battery kicking inside
your fucking head?
You know,
they might have a nine volt battery,
they might have shit jeans and a poor
like database to draw from genetically.
No one in their,
you know,
their,
their genes,
their ancestries had been any different
than them and they've gotten this far,
so there's no need to adapt.
No.
Yeah.
So it's like,
you know,
you come across a wild pig or you come
across a pig that's in a pen and they're,
they're completely different animals.
Maybe that was what's going on and
then it that case we're fucked.
Yeah,
exactly.
Maybe that's why wars keep going on and
maybe that's why religion keeps working.
Yeah.
Maybe it's like,
it's almost impossible.
Have you ever seen the movie idiocracy no,
I haven't seen it.
What I heard,
it's funny,
I just wanted to see that movie by now.
I know I got upset because,
um,
a couple of people accused me of stealing
the idea for that bit that I had for
my special,
the bit about the dumb people
outbreeding smart people.
Right.
First of all,
that's not a,
an original concepts.
I've been thinking that forever.
Of course.
And second of all,
my special came out before that movie
came out and it was something I worked on
for years before the special.
It's just a,
you know,
everybody's had that thought.
So because of that I bought
it and I never watched it.
I didn't want to see how
close it is to my shit.
You are paced.
You know,
you get in these,
um,
these defending yourself,
there's no need to defend yourself
and say it's gross when you,
that's one of the things
about communicating with
people online is the anonymity
and the deal.
Sometimes you're,
you're dealing with people,
you're just dealing with like,
why are you behaving this way?
Like why are you communicating this way?
This is the only way you do.
The only reason why people
would communicate that way
is because there's a lack
of social repercussions.
Here's no can say anything and get away.
You don't feel it.
You know,
it's like the reason why people in their
car can give you the fuck you fucking,
when they wouldn't do that,
if they were just on the
street a few feet from,
you know,
that fantasy in a car right next to you.
They just,
because there's a window and because
there's a door and a window and a door and
some space in between that they're like,
fuck you,
you fucking bitch.
You wouldn't do it.
Why you would do then the person you
will to be a crazy person to do that in
person.
But there's a detachment
because of the automobiles.
We can't feel each other.
See each other.
We see we're separated by some
shit and we know that it's safe.
It's the same feeling that you feel
when you're at the zoo and you know,
you don't feel uncomfortable when
you're standing next to a fucking bear.
He's supposed to be shitting your
pants when you're looking at the bear.
Man,
that is not normal to get
comfortable looking at a bear.
You should be terrified man.
That fucking thing is
only a few feet from you.
Trust that glass.
Let's get outta here.
Yeah,
man.
It's uh,
the repercussions of dealing
with people answered that.
It's very annoying.
Do you,
uh,
do you post stuff on the Internet?
You have blogs or anything like that?
I mean,
my life has been so damn crazy lately
that I've just constantly teaching and
writing,
teaching a badge.
I mean,
I love a lot of bad shit
happened because my um,
my wife died a few months ago.
Charlie.
Good man.
We are all the baby.
So you know,
you can imagine that alone takes a
hell of a lot of time and energy and
everything.
And then,
you know,
steel working in teaching,
writing,
doing.
So I'm just like,
you know,
keep up on,
email,
Facebook kind of stuff.
But I've been trying to save whatever
energy level after cause there's not a
whole lot of,
by the end of the day,
you know,
you're doing 7 million things at once.
So yeah.
Do you take a lot of vitamins and
eat healthy and the to work on back,
cause I feel it in my body and all last
few months it's just too much stress,
too much over the scene.
So I'm just throwing,
I'd been used to,
you know,
I worked out forever for 20 years now
this last year I've hardly been able to.
And so of course,
you know,
all of this stuff then takes a toll.
So I'm trying to,
you know,
not become a,
the Unabomber or something.
Got The for them evidencing that nobody
body but at the same time save some
energy for just beneath in,
Ya know?
Yeah.
That's important,
man.
It's important.
It's very hard.
Especially people with children with
people don't understand when they have a
baby.
A is you,
you now have a human being taken care of.
It's not like a pet,
not like you have to be
with it 24 hours a day.
If it's little and you
have to take a shit,
you know what you have to do.
You have to lock it in the room with you
while you're taking a shit or you have
to like keep it from pulling the things
out of the drawers and the killing
itself,
climbing up on something
that they can't support.
You know?
It's like,
it's a constant,
like it's a lot of work.
Yeah.
So that anybody has kids.
I'm like,
how the hell does anybody
do this know though is,
and I love her.
I mean she's not even a hard baby,
you know?
She's an easy sweet bay steel.
She's amazing.
Nice.
Yeah.
It's,
it takes a lot of energy
and what you get out of it,
their little drug dispensers,
which you get out of it,
is love and the purest form possible
cut straight from the source.
The love that you get from babies,
man.
Oh my God.
You don't,
people don't,
who don't have kids really will never
truly understand this experience because
you can think you love
a dog because you do.
I love our dogs that see they're sweet
and they give me kisses and I'm happy,
but you don't.
There's a feeling that you get when it's
a baby that's your own flesh and blood,
and they're just little bundles of
love and they're a little bundles of
happiness,
and you can directly influence them.
You can directly,
you know,
shaped their life and they're
looking for you to do that.
And then they need you
around all the time.
And they constantly want
you to hold them into,
kicked them up and touch them.
You know,
the constantly screaming
for you to touch them.
You know,
it's,
it's amazing to watch
that from the source,
you know,
to see an uh,
uh,
a life form,
a unique life form with no language
that's communicating with just intent and
noises.
It wants you to do things for it and
what it wants you to do is real simple,
wants,
love and wants to play.
It doesn't want to be left alone.
It makes sense.
So much work.
Yeah.
So how do you,
how do you,
uh,
keep saying,
dude,
you have like a workout you
do or meditation or yoga
or anything that I think on
it.
Yeah,
them right now I have been
burning the candle on both ends.
So I don't know that I have to go down
and search your dad cause I don't think
I've been doing a good job at hits.
I think of being the handling things.
But I'm feeding lately my body
kind of giving me signals like,
hey man,
you are going over the edge.
You don't need to tone it down,
smoke cigarettes or anything.
Do you know that's good.
So now they workout has
always been my thing.
But then again,
when you don't have the
physical time anymore,
we're and everything.
So I need to find the tie ins to do it.
And so that's kind of what I'm working on,
on being able to just train
again and do all this stuff.
Cause I mean with martial arts
I've been doing it 20 years.
It's been like one of the things that
you do day in and day out forever and
suddenly you don't do that anymore.
You're like,
Oh shit,
your body goes through withdrawal.
You know,
you feel weird.
Do you feel,
so it seems key to do it cause it
doesn't matter how busy you get,
it's key to your health in a way.
Yeah.
I remember I tore a ligament in my leg.
It was the first like real serious
injury that took me out for months and
months.
I tore a knee ligament and
how to get it reconstructed.
And then I didn't work
out for a long time.
And it was the first time in my
life that I hadn't done that.
Right.
You know?
And I had always used martial
arts for blowing off steam.
And now all of a sudden I was
at this place where I was like,
wow,
I just,
I,
you know,
I'm not in control of my emotions as well.
I'm like more short temper.
I'm not in,
I don't feel my body the same way.
Like you know when you
use your body a lot,
you develop this like real tight
relationship with your body.
Like how it moves and,
and it makes you want to eat healthy.
It makes you want to take
care of it because you realize
that it's communicating
with you is communicating with
you through movement and through,
you know,
your,
your desire and intent to do something
and it's actual ability to perform what
your desire and intent is and you get
this relationship with your body and I
didn't have it anymore.
I had no relationship with my body.
I was like,
wow,
this is weird.
Everyday I just wake up and
eat and piss and go through,
you know what I'm saying?
I just go to my,
that's what I'm using my body for.
It's just a vehicle I'm
not communicating with.
Welcome to the life of
most people in the ward.
Yeah.
Right.
You communicate with
your body through things,
you know,
through sex,
through,
through martial arts,
through dance,
through the,
you know,
you communicate when you require your
body to move in very specific ways.
Yeah.
You know,
and there's,
there's,
there's a consciousness to that that's,
you know,
very uniquely its own,
the consciousness of the full couldn't
cut the full focus and concentration of
someone utilizing their body.
You know,
because I really do believe that
that is an element of the whole,
and that you have to,
in order to be optimally healthy,
you have to have the whole together and
have to have the mind must be healthy.
The consciousness must be healthy,
the body must be held.
Totally.
Yeah.
And I went through a long period,
it was like six months,
you know,
rehabbing my knee after the surgery
and everything like that where I still
couldn't kick a bag,
I couldn't box,
I couldn't,
couldn't run.
That really says,
yeah.
It makes you realize,
it makes you really fucking appreciate
your body when you can though.
Seriously.
So what martial arts
where you're doing it?
It's funny,
I started out regionally,
you know,
with watching the TV series too many
times I was dislike how long to go on the
mountain with Master Yada
showing me how to fly in the air.
And it also started out with a lot
of Chinese martial arts and then I
progressively moved to more self defense
oriented thing and then kind of AED
opposite of what most people do.
We start out with very aggressive
and then they mellow out.
I started out with the whole,
it's all about Zan and boy three and
thing and now and just like shut up.
I just rice solely,
just all about combat sports and
the submission grappling in MMA,
the kind of thing.
Well I think you know,
there,
there is uh,
there's definitely a mindset to the
eastern martial arts that is being lost in
the transition to combat sports.
You know,
to look at in combat sports,
there's,
there's something to be
gained from that mindset.
What people don't
understand is that like the,
the ancient Japanese in
a martial arts masters,
you know,
the reason why they practice
Zen thinking wasn't because,
uh,
it's just,
you know,
a thing they did that you know,
really doesn't need to
be replicated today.
Know what they were doing
was in order to have a way,
in order to have a way
of thinking of life,
they were disciplining the mind to behave
on very specific frequencies and to
have control over itself.
And that in your discipline and
in your honor and your code,
you have control over your emotions.
You have control over your body better.
You have control over your psyche better
because you have an ethic because you
have a coat.
And that there's,
there's a reason for that.
This is,
it benefits you in combat.
It benefits you to be sturdy of mind.
So in order to practice
this mental discipline,
it actually puts you in a
better position for victory.
That's why it's there.
Shut down.
I remember,
I'm not the,
I think are kind of a we pattern.
So every time I've coached in photography,
no I got,
I got freaked out.
I get scared when I have to fight.
You know,
some guys are,
you know,
you read a checklist dial or Randy,
these guys who speak to date,
they don't know what
it means to be afraid.
I'm like,
what the fuck you mean?
It's like the scariest thing in the world.
There's this guy was being
training to knock your
head off.
So I walked up and the
days before the tiny,
when I stepped on the mat,
I feel like every singing
my body's shutting down.
I'm about to die kind of
feeling you every scene,
freezers and,
and so I can see how,
you know,
the whole zen thing is not about some
having some strange mystical authorities
about how the,
you deal with the fact that this is what
you're gonna do and you do it without
too much attachment or because
attachment will breed fear.
Fear will shut you down
and then you'll get killed.
Yeah.
You got to control your body.
That's really ultimately what it is.
And the,
the ability to control your mind is
the same as the ability to control your
body.
Cause if you can't control your mind,
you can't control your emotions.
That can run a mock your possibilities.
The real problem is you're intelligent.
That's the real problem.
And it's true.
And when you're intelligent,
you realize,
hey,
we don't have to do this.
This is an elective choice you're making
to go and enter your body and just some
physical combat with another man.
That's,
that's intelligence,
that's intelligent.
You're,
you're,
you're a smart person to think that way.
Your body thinks it's going to fight,
you know,
and your body doesn't want to do it.
So it starts,
you know,
just really essentially
trying to pull you out of it.
But I didn't have the same time.
It's like the most instructive thing in
the ward because he teaches you to get
rid of attachments because you know,
you'll leave with attachment of fierce
and all these things about you hope that
the universe is not going to do this
and that to you and that you can end the
realities in combat.
Like in life.
You don't control Jack Shit,
you do the best you can and then it's
out of your aunts and you need to be able
to live through it despite the
obvious fear that kicks in from south
preservation.
And so he's like,
hey man,
bait man,
maybe you die in a second.
So what?
It's not good.
It doesn't feel good to work hard,
but it's good to work hard,
you know,
it's good.
It's good to train hard,
it's good to push your
body and your spirit,
you know?
And that is a part of it.
Your spirit,
you know,
I have friends that are men that have,
and then I'm not talking about you,
Brian,
that are um,
that have no experience whatsoever in,
um,
in any sort of difficult
physical endeavor.
And it haunts them.
It haunts them.
Like they get insecure when they're
around guys who are athletic,
it'll,
they'll say,
you know,
dicky things and it's like to disarm
this person of their masculinity because
they've never truly face their own
physicality and they're terrified of it.
It's fascinating.
It's fascinating to watch.
Watch some have like these little weird
sort of semi meltdowns and they're
around,
you know,
strong men and he's like the least you
train the tougher you think you are.
That's the way it goes.
You know?
He's like,
no worries about,
oh I'm this stuff got done.
When you step up,
you quickly find out that just guys
are funny when they want to talk about
Monday food and bar fights
toy ya to four 15 times.
It's like,
yeah,
it's fine.
Oh,
you're fine.
15 people that don't know what the fuck
they're doing or your soccer punching
people when you're envious,
this no train at all and
you've knocked down 15 dudes,
I'm okay know you're going to get
fucked up if you keep this up.
One day you got to run into boss route
and at the bar and he's going to fucking
do what I was.
Instructional videos on your head,
Bang,
Sag.
Imagine hope to put some the bully asshole
and you run into a guy like boss and
then a bar.
Oh,
what a mistake.
Especially if he tries to be nice to you.
And you mistake that for him being weak.
Lipsey's yeah,
we were watching,
I had Eddie Bravo in here the other
day and we were watching a Minotauro
Nogueira versus Bob Sapp.
Oh,
that's awesome.
That's classic classic.
Brian,
you,
you saw it too because it's really,
it was a,
it was a cartoon fight,
a real cartoon fight.
And one of the,
in my opinion's the best
example of technique over
power that this Guy Minataro
this 230 pound guy was ever repeat
this 350 plus pound monster of a man.
Didn't even look real.
That is an amazing,
amazing fight.
And that's a,
I mean,
that's a guy,
I mean editorial,
he's a,
he's a real martial artist.
He is a,
he's a real like true warrior.
You know,
a guy who became a master of Jujitsu and
then became a great striker to add onto
it and was just willing to fight anybody.
And I think it started way back in
the day cause I mean when he was,
I forget Danny 11 whatever,
when he had that car accident and he was
sitting like hospital for like a year,
a year where they tell him
you'll never walk again.
Maybe you law may be definitely no
sparks and he goes on to become an MMA
champion and say they'd say
something about a guy's personality.
I remember when he was
at the top of his game,
man,
when he was triangling
everybody and you know,
you just saw you Jitsu on a level
that you had never seen before.
Like all the sudden this bad ass
heavyweight who was tough as fuck though,
who had a wicked guard.
Oh wicked Jujitsu game was
hitting Anaconda chokes on
dudes and fucking strangle
him from his back and you're like,
Whoa,
do it is on another level.
That was like,
to me like a real victory for technique
and mixed mixed martial arts in my
opinion in editorial like embodies like
this era where people like learn like
Whoa,
that's possible too.
Like that was,
we were not seeing guys on,
on the highest levels submitting guys
the way Minataro was not as you know,
he's so awesome.
How about the Cro cop fight?
He gets battered by Cro
cop in the first round,
right fucking smashed head kicks
by the guy who knocked out.
Everybody would had cakes and somehow or
another he eats it and he's okay and he
gets up at the bottom of the round at the,
at the end of the round he gets head
kicked and dropped like seconds before the
round ends and he thought the referee
stopped the fight and the referee was
like,
nope.
The rounds over.
He's like,
okay,
then stop this fucking fight.
And he goes back and he takes him down.
He armbars I'm in the second round,
but he took up painting
in that first round like,
God damn,
that dude is tough.
And like,
you've got to love it as a guys or
stuck or rabbi or does the guys,
all my crazy wars Sakharova by
the time his career was over,
he was essentially going in to the,
to the ring with his legs.
Mummify his knees were so bad that he
would have the tape that would go all the
way up to the top of his thigh and
all the way down to his ankles.
It was crazy.
Yeah,
that was a,
that was another guy that was like a real,
like classic technique,
a technique and heart oversize guy.
Remember when he fought Quinton Jackson
and Quinto kept his land rover and he
got his back.
I'm just flowing.
I'm like,
Jesus,
how do you stay relaxed when
some monster is lifting?
Doing well.
His Jujitsu was beautiful.
He was so tough.
He was so like willing to take punishment.
You know,
he was,
he was technical,
but it was also brave.
He's willing to take punishment
and essentially really,
he should have been 170 pounder.
Yup.
I mean,
he was walking around at 189 pounds
without cutting any weight at all.
And he was a little fat and he was taken
on the heavy weights and he mentioned
that he thought that was kind of a
career he would have had that guy fucking
beat Conan Sylvia with an arm bar.
Remember that Shit.
Kokona and went for a fucking Kamora.
He spun around and caught him in an
arm bar that was a pure victory of
technique,
oversize.
That was a clear example of that.
He was an amazing fighter
and know another one who was,
you know,
embodied that Japanese warrior spirit,
and that's what they loved about him
and his willingness to go out there and
throw it down with anybody,
anyone,
even Vendelay Silva who beat
the fuck out of him three times.
He kept stepping up,
kept stepping up,
man.
And that last one,
when he got knocked out and Vandelay
caught him with two punches and it
literally,
he sent him flying through the air
as he skid unconscious on his back.
Like wow,
the Melvin Manhoef fight when
he fought Melvin Manhoef.
No,
Jesus,
I feel bad for the guy.
And he just took so many beatings.
Oh my God.
No one's taken more
beatings and Sakharova dude,
Melvin Manhoef is a destroyer.
When that guy starts teeing off on you,
he's one of the most terrifying
strikers in any martial law.
You know,
when he's attacking and he's just so
strong and fast and just blasting Sakuraba
and the fucking guy came back
after that and he kept fighting.
I mean he's,
he's still fighting.
Yeah,
I know.
I mean,
I feel it's weird is perverted.
Like,
well I want to see him fight,
but then I want him to retire,
you know?
Oh,
I would love to him to retire.
We can watch this old fights.
So many classics.
He was involved in so many
fight of the year candidates,
you know,
I mean,
even when he was broken up,
when it was that like a year ago or two
years ago when you had to fight with
Gallese Guy,
I think he was,
or he pulled the guy in
any bar and a guy like,
he seemed like 50 straight times,
no protection.
And the guy stayed with it so he could
get the knee bar and wind define how do
you stay with that technique?
Fuck for,
it's amazing.
He's got unbelievable determination.
What about the Xerox guys?
Fight wears ear,
fell off his ear.
Literally it's,
it's a,
Sakharova has these
gigantic cauliflower ears.
So for people who don't know what that
means when you wrestle a lot or you get
hit in the ear a lot,
when it breaks up the tissue,
it fills up with fluid and
blood and then it hardens it.
Like it becomes like almost like Cartlidge
like really fixed up and you have to
have that cut out.
And a lot of guys,
they get an ear that becomes like this.
I mean Lou or loose like a
mouse is under their skin.
It's,
and that's what it
looked like with soccer.
Rob of the whole thing was deformed.
Randy coture actually uses his
in grappling cause it's hard,
right?
So when he takes guys down,
he'll actually like shove his ear
and to parts of them and make them
uncomfortable.
He'll fucking jab them with his ears,
man.
Those are,
those are hard weapons
on the side of his head.
It's really kind of crazy.
But soccer rob was here was really
fucked up and it had always had tape on.
It was always getting cut
and training and shed.
And this dude hit him with something.
I forgot what he hit him with,
but the fucking ear was
hanging off of his head.
It was just hanging on
and there's a romps.
This is like,
dude,
you're fucking ear.
Like even stopped fighting.
It was like,
Whoa,
dude,
you might want to look at that.
What's going on here?
They stitched it up as he
fought since then he did.
He's,
you know,
my rating.
I hope he stops.
He's not going to stop.
He's not going to stop,
but they're not going to have them stop.
They're going to,
they're going to keep asking him to
keep doing it and he'll get doughnut.
But I mean,
if new hires Meyer to [inaudible],
they would pay it and we'd like all the
legends and then mellow matches and they
would even make sense.
At least throw him in with werewolves.
Yeah.
That's just fuck it up.
Is He,
does he still smoke?
She,
you know,
I'd never known to reality.
You'd always hear the story about hymns
chain smoking and they can all the time.
That's what I always heard.
I think that's true,
man.
Yeah.
He trained hard,
but I'm pretty sure he actually chained,
smoked and drank.
They lead.
Ever make a movie about that guy.
He was amazing.
Such a diverse culture because they
are so by the book in so many ways.
But when the guys golf
model they really go,
yeah,
they get Mohawks and
tattoo their whole body.
And there's one guy I had,
I love this guy that I put in the book
isn't there is eat Q is the zen master
from,
I want to say the 39 [inaudible]
49 or something like that.
And this is your book
on the Warrior's path.
These one is the one
that's called religion,
religion book.
This dude was the illegitimate
son of the emperor of Japan.
And so they add to kind of his man,
just hit him in a monastery somewhere
so that he wouldn't get killed.
Imbalance,
conspiracy,
trying to get rid of the possible here.
So you know,
this poor kid grew up in the middle of
this fucked up zen monastery in the cold
and whatever,
just trying to stay alive and so fine.
You know,
not the most fun in the ward,
but he goes up,
no way.
Absolute genius.
Everybody said,
Jesus,
nobody get us Zanda way.
This guy does his sorts marriages.
So these is so that precisely
because he's so smart.
He just flipped him off one day and he
decided when they give you mean Zandy
every seen,
they called the certificate
of enlightenment where a
master certified a yard.
Truly enlightened.
Wow.
He picked it up and he was like,
certificate of enlightenment.
Are you fucking kidding me?
You know,
he burned it and he was like,
come on.
You know,
and that that is pretty,
pretty fast.
I sued.
Really mean and trying to keep
him in the fold by giving him,
you know,
will make you add both of these mourners.
Three step a week later,
nobody can find him.
They find this poem that
he left behind saying,
[inaudible] Jesus a
week in this monastery.
I can't take it anymore.
If anybody's looking for me,
I mean they're at the brothel or at the
Saki sharp and that's the rest of his
life.
He goes off being does cut off one.
That in teacher was main
passions are Zana uh,
hookers and sad.
That's all daddy loves,
you know,
eat Q is a key.
K why you wow,
it's my full time here.
I loved it.
I loved that he figured it out.
Yeah.
It sounds like my friend bad,
Bobby Bobby from Vancouver,
he figured it out.
Hookers and just Saki bezerk
and end to him is Zen and uh,
it was all to heat it to he Maria Zan
was leaving life with full awareness.
That is then you can do it.
Meditating in a mountain,
if that makes you feel good,
you can do it in a brothel
if that makes you feel good.
It's about having full awareness.
It's not about what you're doing as much
as about whether you are awake and the
are alive to what's going on or whether
you're going through the motion and
you're not really there and whether or
not you're just reacting to every single
thing mindlessly around you.
And by the way,
there really is no true enlightenment
because even true enlightenment for a
human is just true
enlightenment for human.
Our little brains can't really,
we're not set up right.
We have,
we have,
we are essentially just like this old
shitty computer we have that's running all
this equipment.
We were really do not have the hardware
to deal with the scenario at hand.
We're fucked.
So even enlightenment for a person
that's just enlightenment for a person,
you know,
like the best you could do
is keep it together mildly.
Cause I mean,
you know,
I mean it's,
it's so funny.
It's was like,
you know,
everybody is searching
for that and you know,
what you're searching for is ultimately
a better feeling about your experience
here.
Right.
That's what we're all searching for.
Whether it's through religion or
through meditation or through Yoga.
I have a friend who their
family was very religious,
uh,
until recently,
like a few years ago,
they started to kind of,
I don't know what,
what brought him out of it,
but they started kind of
see it differently and now
they're experiencing their
first year or two years completely
away from their church and the wife is
starting to get into yoga.
And you know,
the dude is like,
we experiment with a bunch of different
things and just trying to figure out
what the fuck is going on in the world.
But it's weird to watch
someone come out of it.
It's weird to watch someone go,
you know what?
Maybe maybe this is a mistake here.
Well you guys are nice.
I enjoy hanging out with you.
But Shit,
come on.
Like they're,
their own mind has evolved their,
their,
their personal consciousness
of all past an ideology.
Right.
And that's a big decision to me.
Very hard.
Huge.
It's bigger than breaking
up with a girlfriend.
I don't know about that.
But
it depends on how religion
you are religious you are.
But if you're like,
I'm really active with the church
and then you're going to lunch,
it's an arm,
it doesn't get any bigger.
It also depends how tight that girl is.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's true.
Right.
And whether or not she's a freak.
Yeah.
Whether or not,
you know,
just turn it loose for one day.
She's loyal,
but you're trying to lose from one
day and she's in a fucking gang bang.
And you can't take that gang bang back
and there's a thing where she always
really wanted to get with a black guy,
but she never had
no.
The mom when she's loose,
do you see that video of the
octopus walking out of the water?
How creepy is that?
Well,
you know there's a video of an
octopus climbing out of its aquarium,
walking across the floor and going up
to another aquarium that's in the same
room and eating fish and then
climbing back and as aquarium.
Yeah,
we're seeing some,
I know this,
I haven't seen it,
but the reason why I know this is because
a friend was trying to explain to me
how intelligent octopuses are that they
can take food and put it in a jar and
the octopus,
we'll unscrew the jar and get at the food
and that a guy was missing some of his
tropical fish and he had a couple of
fish tanks and one of them was right next
to,
you know the octopus is right
next to this one with like,
this is really expensive fish.
It's fucking octopus was climbing out,
climbing up into the next tank,
lifting the fucking lid up and getting
inside and eating the fish and then
climbing back to his place.
Put a time.
So I really thought about it.
It's like,
listen,
if I hang out here,
this motherfuckers going to know
that I can get it to this tag.
You know?
So the dude had a set up a camera.
He set up a camera and
caught this octopus.
Still haven't seen the video though.
So it might be harsh.
It might be in that legend tweet.
Yeah.
Tweet it.
You,
you whoever's listening where
there's enough people listening.
We don't need to tweak this.
This is ridiculous.
I'm going to leave it at that,
Brian.
Um,
no,
I mean,
I tweeted so I can see it.
I don't know if somebody,
yeah,
if they find it folks tweeted,
somebody,
if it's out there,
it might not be out there.
I might not be real.
But,
um,
uh,
how do we get on this subject
of Octopus's killing things?
If the climbing out of being intelligent,
you have it.
You've seen the,
uh,
the,
evidence for a cracking.
Have you seen the evidence
for a giant octopus of legend?
You know,
there's always been a legend of an octopus
that can devour ships and you know,
a huge whale eating well,
they actually have found evidence of this
thing like a really boy inside of your
octopus.
No,
they found,
they actually found whale bones
and the whale bones are fucked up.
And so that means there's something
that is big enough to go kill a god damn
well.
And they also found fossilized
imprints of giant suction cups.
And that's what leads him to
believe that the possibly,
see,
the thing about an octopus
is there's no bones really.
There's nothing going to be left.
There's no fossilize octopus.
It's not like a bird or something else
where you can get the structure of the
animal.
There's,
you know,
it's essentially all soft
tissue except for its beak.
So it dissolves.
It doesn't exist anymore.
But it was on the ocean floor
that they had these imprints.
He's fossilized imprints of what looked
like massive suction cups of a huge
tentacle.
And by that they're,
they're making this pretty
reasonable hypothesis,
you know,
and the,
the bones of the whale
being all fucked up.
And then these giant suction cups,
they're like,
oh,
they're probably was this
real monster but lived.
I mean,
if there's a whale,
why wait?
Just a whale's ridiculous.
And it's right there.
It's weird as it gets,
man,
a super smart,
giant big thing.
They can't do anything
and it has to breathe air.
You know,
like why it lives in the ocean
and it breathes air like Watson.
I know.
That's so stupid.
You know the design that
I didn't quite workout.
It lives in the water but yet can't,
it can go down the water for a little bit,
but it's got to come up for air
and then it can't even stop.
It can't stop because of it stops.
Then it'll fucking sink
and then it'll drown.
That's fucking,
how do they,
do they even sleep?
They don't even sleep.
They think they like,
like dolphins.
They're like partially sleep.
I'd be like shut most of their
brain off for a couple hours a day.
You see this video,
the octopus eye opening the jar to get
the food inside and then shutting the
jar.
Oh yeah.
I have seen this.
Yeah.
Have you seen the OCTA?
Was Jack the shark?
No.
What?
Yeah,
there was another one in the aquarium.
They're finding a lot
of sharks were missing.
They're trying to figure out what
the fuck was going on and uh,
they put a video camera up
and they saw you watched.
That one definitely exists.
If you look for a octopus,
each shark and it's fucking awkward.
Let's just jump on the
shark and Jack theme.
It's just Jujitsu.
Once they get ahold of his body,
he's,
he's helped eat them.
Yeah.
You know,
it's really simple.
Everybody thinks all do.
Who would win and shark or an octopus?
Oh Dude,
for sure.
Shark the fuck it would.
Right?
It's supposed to move fast.
Shark is stupid.
They try to fight you.
He just wrapped that bitch up,
watch this shit.
It's kind of crazy.
It's hard to see on this TV behind you.
Yeah.
The,
yeah.
There you go.
TV buying,
and I could look at this one back here.
Well,
this is act two was
just fuck the shark up,
man.
This shark was like,
yeah man,
I'm a shark.
I'm just going to fuck somebody up today.
That shark never thought that
anyone is going to eat him.
Sharks don't even really
have any natural predators.
You know what I mean?
Well,
the flux run around eating sharks.
Occasionally an Orca will kill a shark,
but they only do it because the
sharks are too close to their babies.
They're not like trying to eat him.
It's pretty rare.
Look at this stupid fucking shark.
Yeah,
man.
I'm just running shit down here.
That's a live one right there.
Okay,
that's crazy.
He's waiting.
How long can the octopus
live outside of water?
That when I saw that video I was like,
isn't he?
Doesn't he need water?
I don't know,
but lobsters are skin live
outside a long fucking time.
You ever got a lobster in
the mail and they're nice.
Yeah,
you can do that in the mail.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
and they're on ice.
It'll get it.
Here he goes,
bitch,
come here.
Shark swims over the octopus.
The octopus just wraps this bitch
up with some like raw jujitsu.
That's total Jujitsu,
bro.
Look at his hooks.
Yeah,
he's got his back.
He's like,
oh no,
no,
no.
My friend right now,
this is della Hiva guard
cause he's trying to get away.
It's like our Masa.
He's trying to bite them to the shark.
Might bite him a little,
but you know,
here's the crazy thing about us.
Or you can bite their limbs off.
It doesn't matter.
Bitch growing other one,
they grow another one.
They're super is the super adaptable.
So this shark is biting them,
but so what?
And he's just getting jacked.
He's getting totally Anaconda in here.
Spun around.
Yeah,
there there's suction
cups are bad ass man.
It's a bad ass design.
You know,
everything just pulls it into one center
where there's a giant fucking beak and
that beat just jacks your Hass.
Wow,
that's cool.
That's nature.
Meanwhile,
that's crazy thing is their eyes
and our eyes are very similar.
They're very similar biologically,
which is amazing.
Like me,
somewhere along the line,
some hundreds of millions of years ago,
we were probably cousins of an octopus
and then we branched off into different
ways in the ocean floor.
And you know,
we went one way,
they went another way.
They went this way of just blending in
their environment and Jack and sharks.
And here we are jacking the world.
Awesome.
Um,
so back to religion.
Let's come back to it.
Did you,
um,
what did you ask?
Did I ask you,
um,
what was the oldest religion?
Yeah,
I mean I guess some form
of Fannie Mae's him.
He's basically,
so you were telling me about the cave,
for lack of a better term,
a scholar Scolito animism or shamanism
or however you want to call it.
[inaudible] Jones.
And they have,
you know,
enormous variation from
one tribe to deny that,
but they have some common themes they
tend to see like the nature as alive,
you know,
in nature is alive.
We'd speed eight to spirits and everybody
seeing from threes to animals to all
sorts of stuff.
Did.
I kind of like star wars that there's a
power in everything forced to watch like
in a forest.
Exactly.
That you cannot be in 20 times.
No,
morality is not about,
you have to be a drink first.
Right.
So there's,
there's some cool stuff
out there that's uh,
but um,
but yeah,
he vats that Amanda's we from one type
to the next and it wasn't written down,
you know,
it wasn't an organized or
you joining that sense.
And I mean some of that's
two likes these do these day,
you know,
and some tribal culture.
It's was steel.
What's going on?
What's the official a
belief as far as like,
you know,
what's taught in schools when
it comes to cattle worship?
Why are there so many
cattle worshiping trials?
Delicious.
Yeah,
exactly.
That's,
that's definitely true.
That's they worshiped them as gods and
they don't even eat them in some parts of
the world.
Right.
In the eye and stuff.
How much does that have to
do with psychedelic drugs?
So that's why with the theories about
Hinduism is about how a lot of it began
with Salma and saw him.
I was going to see there to be some
people say was Amanita Mascara,
you know,
the marsh or Amanda,
they say that they also say strew
Feria cubensis and they say,
and it might've been um,
a combination,
sort of a cocktail that they put together
right now it's amazing that if you
know about the,
their religion and the place
that Soma played in it,
that it was lost.
Like we don't know what it is.
Yep.
No names.
They would talk about Salma being greater
than all these different things and
Soma being amazing.
But yeah,
we don't know what Soma is.
Somehow or another they lost with Soma
is there's that guy a garden west.
And actually I think I was
in the book in there too,
cause
it was too much of a fun story.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That chapter in title the piece drink I,
how do you,
how is it that one go
and Watson is the one who initially made
psychedelic mushrooms popular with a
western America.
Oh yeah.
I read a chapter entitled Peace Drinking
piece of drinking draggy priests
created into Islam because it's one of
the theory that Western as about that is
that he believes that he believes he
was at many times carry out this summer.
And the way he figured it out,
he went through a bunch of these books
are referring to Sam and he was saying,
you know,
they keep talking about a plant
but they don't talk about leaves.
They don't talk about,
you know,
they refer to stem,
they refer to somewhere crap.
Right.
And then so he was thinking he was
starting to go into mushroom direction and
then he finds out this piece of literature
or from somewhere else where it's
some Shyman in Siberia I think was
talking about how they feel terror Amanita
Muscarella and he had read
about these three pl field.
Third are they using for some hour?
They do a couple of sinks to better wait.
And then there's a human
filter and he was like,
what the hell is a human filter?
He find out that if you
take Amanita Mascara,
you'll get the high by yours.
So guy the really nauseous and
in your purse or your drink,
somebody else getting the high,
but they get stuck with a crappy part.
They get all the side effects.
Your dog.
Well,
I know that people drink their own
parents when they're tripping it take an
Amnio or when they're taking an fairy
cubensis they'll drink their own urine and
they blast off.
Apparently I talked to this dude,
he was like,
I was like,
I don't want to drink my piss.
This is crazy.
And was like,
dude,
trust me.
Drink your like,
he's like,
I'm tripping balls and they're telling
me I need to drink my piss to get higher
than this.
He goes,
I don't want to get out in this,
like trust me.
And he goes,
okay.
I drink my piss.
And he goes and all of a sudden it was
like a tornado opened up in front of my
eyes and I got sucked through the center
of it and said it was the craziest trip
and the most enlightening
trooper was life.
But yeah,
it,
yeah,
that's at least is your own in these
cases even closer because it's somebody
else's,
it just cause you don't want
to get the side effects.
But I may or may not have watched people
drank animals pis who I may or may not.
If I can't discuss money,
she paid for that.
I can't discuss this until now.
It was in person.
I didn't pay anything.
I actually got paid,
but it might not really be real.
Uh,
I can,
and I can't discuss this till uh,
ironically and a totally unrelated
after fear factor starts hearing.
Which Harrison?
Cool.
Well,
um,
the human filter was a popular thing.
People would just sell their own.
Would they sell it where
they just make a deal?
I'll tell you what,
like why line in some 40,000 year old
book or something so nobody really knows.
And he could be the west.
He speculating going off
the deep end with that.
Could be,
but it's an interesting,
it's a fan theory if nothing else.
How many do Mascara is a very strange
mushroom because they believe it's not
only variable genetically,
but it's variable by location seasonally.
And that some of them might
not even be psychoactive.
There's some of them might not even work.
Right.
You know,
I've,
I've tried am Anita and
to when nothing happened,
right.
You know,
I tried to,
I didn't,
I went on a,
a combat atory experience.
We tried the Amanita,
we tried it for a few
hours and nothing took.
So then we took some regular
mushrooms and then we blast it off.
So it was a combination of the
two of them was like ultra potent.
The emoney that did something weird,
but it wasn't really like getting you off.
It was just like getting you
to this weird head space.
I was like,
Whoa,
what's going on here?
Like is this,
this is what this stuff is like.
I just think it wasn't strong enough.
It wasn't good enough.
And I think,
um,
you know,
there's parts of the
world where it's like,
Eh,
you know,
where they really know how to do it
and we'll really in Siberia special ed.
And it's fascinating.
This thing about Siberia is how the
Amanita Mascara mushroom is essentially
Christmas.
It's essentially Santa Claus.
When people don't know that the,
the Christmas theme and the mushroom
theme are so closely related,
they're eating the same color,
right?
How many Anita must grow
mushroom is Santa Claus.
It's red,
you know,
and it has a Michael Rise relationship
with a certain coniferous trees so that
it grows only under those trees,
just like packages under
your fucking Christmas tree.
I mean,
it's really amazing.
and you know,
and people would gather them and the
way to drive them out was they would put
them on the fucking trees,
on the branches of the trees.
So the son would get them,
it would dry them out.
Like it's like,
that's the ornaments on the trees.
It's like all of it is there.
It's like there's so many connections
and it's been argued that,
uh,
you know,
someone told me the Coca Cola was the
first one to actually make a red and white
Santa Claus.
Then he was a different color before then.
But that's not really true.
Um,
there's,
there's evidence of red and
white Sanchez from long time ago,
you know,
and,
but that the Santa doesn't even matter.
What really matters is the fucking
presents under the tree the way you know,
the,
the relationship that
it has with the tree.
The reason why we have Christmas trees
and they're always fucking pine trees,
man.
I mean,
the whole thing,
it's like,
wow,
it's,
there's the relationship's so close,
the look,
the color of it,
and the fact that we hang stockings over
the fireplace and those stockings when
the fuck did you ever get a pair of
red and white stockings that you wore?
Right.
You don't button through that tool,
but that's also how they dry
mushrooms out of their home.
They hang them in front of the fireplace
and that's what drives them out.
I would say
it's an incredible like series of,
uh,
whether they're,
they're co coincidences or,
I mean,
I wouldn't say coincidence.
I would say,
you know,
there's,
there's evidence that
there's a relationship and a,
there's a bunch of people
that have studied this.
There's a guy a and Andrew
Ruta g and a young urban,
they've,
they've done a lot of study on this stuff.
And the,
and the great,
Jack Herer was actually writing a book
about this before he died though the
relationship with Christianity
and a mushrooms as well.
He had all these really cool ancient
paintings of people who are naked dancing
and the ecstasy under the very clear,
transparent silhouette
of a shape of a mushroom,
you know,
so it's really amazing stuff.
Like the idea,
and if you ever look at the really old
pictures of Halos that's as fascinating
to old Halos,
like the new halos or like a Frisbee
or like a hula hoop proud and floating
around the back of your head.
But the old Halos,
we're literally on the
underside of a mushroom cap.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And it has the straw
that little lines in it,
just like a mushroom does.
And it's,
it's really a trip when
you see that you go,
oh my God.
Like this is what they were saying was
these people were under the spell of the
mushroom.
They were enlightened,
right.
Because they were under
the spell of the mushroom.
Right.
And there's mushrooms symbology,
like all throughout ancient buildings
and like doorways or mushroom shaped like
literally these,
these,
these temples had mushroom shaped doorway.
Right.
Fuck man.
How many people were
on mushrooms back then?
No,
no Internet.
No TV.
You got to keep entertained somehow.
Yeah.
That's the move,
right?
Yeah.
Damn man.
So when you're teaching these classes,
do you ever get anybody
who's angry at you?
Do you ever get anybody who wants to
talk to you after class and just like,
you know,
hey,
what you're doing is wrong or,
no,
for the most part airmail I mean,
and again,
I tried to do it in a way that I try
not to be offensive to the individual.
I may say something harsh.
I always say something
harsh about the big picture,
but on the,
on an individual lab and he's like,
hey man,
I mean,
it doesn't mean I hate you.
You know?
It's like we're playing here,
we're tossing ideas.
I'm not attached to my ideas.
That would be something that makes sense.
I'll change my mind right now.
You're always like,
I'm not here to defend an ideology.
So it would have been okay,
ours,
we're just playing,
you know,
so people in my little out and once,
why do we have discussions?
I had a Muslim student
who was very nice guy,
but obviously wasn't too keen.
He loved me when I talk
shit about other religious,
but of course he had to sub each.
That's what I started
picking on the Quran.
He had these,
um,
one thing I pick it on was
this passage in the Koran,
the basically justify beating up your
wife if she's disobedient and uh,
he's a nice guy,
so he doesn't really want to support that.
But at the same time he doesn't
want to go it against the Koran.
So he was like struggling and trying
to figure out what do I do with it?
He kept up with this weird
ass theory a week later,
tell him,
you know what?
This is God telling you that
you shouldn't beat up women.
And I'm like,
yeah,
that's the way it,
except that it's saying
that you should [inaudible].
She's like,
no,
no.
He's using saboteurs psychology.
You know,
because he's,
if he tells you not to,
then you get pieces,
then you want to do it.
So firstly,
wait,
he said first Firstie Thal seal
that you should talk to them.
And then if they don't marry forum,
then you banish them to another
room and not only as a last resort,
then you can beat them.
So really styling,
you know,
you shouldn't be the map,
but it's doing it in a smart way.
And I was like,
oh my fucking God,
I it,
can you just take them?
Maybe there's some good stuff
in the Koran and your cat,
some crap.
And can we engineer
the most dogmatic slums
like radical Muslims are
the most dogmatic about it.
What do you find to be
the most ridiculous?
Is there are they are religions,
ridiculous.
The people,
all the ones who believe that there's
only one right way that has been revealed
by God to damn.
And so they are super
hardcore to the magic.
And mostly,
I mean you're talking about Muslim
fundamentalists today in particular,
Mazda,
fundamentalist Christian
fundamentalists throughout metro fees.
Three they mellowed out a lethal today.
They let you paint them.
Yeah,
exactly.
Draw Jesus.
Mohammad a fucking shoot.
You blow your house up.
But uh,
I think he's only in
western Western monotheistic
religions have the tendency to
have,
uh,
an alt s more Arad bead die.
It'll kill you if you
disagree kind of mentality.
Monster Asian seeing so,
I mean,
you can agree,
you can disagree,
but they are kind of like,
Eh,
you know,
if you disagree with the hell cares,
it's the years thing.
Yeah.
Asian martial arts or
Asian rather illusions.
What about,
um,
what do they got?
The idea that the most dogmatic and the
most restrictive religions are really
the religions that have come from
the areas that have like the oldest
civilizations.
Right.
And so almost like,
you know,
like,
like sue mayor,
which is where I rack is,
right.
You know,
really famously is a part of the
world that is still in the dark ages.
Right.
And a lot of ways,
you know,
the,
the battles we're seeing the
Sunni and the Shiites and the,
just the,
the,
the Kurds and all the shit that
happened with Saddam Hussein and,
right.
And you go back to that area.
I mean you,
you say,
well,
you know this,
this area literally was sue mare.
This is,
there is Babylon.
This is where,
you know,
the,
literally the first religions
were created as far as we know.
You know,
and when you think about that,
like the people that are still there,
they're much more influenced by the deep,
deep past,
you know,
then people that have spread out to
all parts of the world as travelers,
especially Americans.
Right.
That's the,
the further,
the last example of a new
continent that we know that,
you know,
just over the last few hundred
years it's been established.
Yeah.
I'm kind of scared of anything
that comes out of the desert.
The desert is a it up place.
I mean it's just some
people do well in it,
but for the most part it's harsh.
Environment matters,
man.
Oh,
do you want to do is you just
squeezed between two rocks but Ada,
your brain,
does it start oozing out of your hand?
[inaudible] so it's like all
religions that come out of the desert.
I can see how the people that come out
of the desert ridge drive from California
to the drive from California to Vegas
and he'd get out and you just smell crime
dude.
Smell fear and anger.
Fear and loathing.
Right,
exactly.
At Arrest Thompson fucking nailed it.
I mean,
it's not a mistake that he drove in a
convertible taking it all in while on
ether.
I come that,
yeah,
that's probably the way
to see it correctly.
No,
so that's with the religions.
I mean really jumped,
come out from beautiful
mountains and reverse and shit.
I'm sure he's going to do something to
its ideology where they are maybe not old
ways,
but for more likely than not,
they're going to have a
more mellow view of life.
Well,
there's only one really mellow religion,
right?
That's Buddhism led these
amazing perky model.
In fact,
I have no problems with,
I mean Sam bags.
I can do that.
Good.
He read some stuff in Buddhism,
but is it's pleasant disagreement,
you know,
it's like,
and they are not as a,
at least for the most part,
as our core trying to shove it down your
throat so it's a little more relaxed to
have a dialogue that's
really appreciate that.
I really appreciate religions
that don't proselytize.
I really appreciate it.
Like two days.
I'm like,
nobody's trying to get you to be a Jew.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
And you really can't even join,
you know,
it's really hard to join,
right?
Yeah.
You've got to marry some chick.
You know,
it's,
my uncle did,
my uncle converted name
is Salvatore Digerlando.
He could really became Jewish.
Um,
yeah.
It's,
um,
it's interesting to me that,
you know,
there's no,
uh,
there's,
there's no,
I wouldn't say there's no new religions,
but there's no new respected religions.
There's everything where you
can look back and feel like,
you know,
some people take Scientology seriously,
but for the most part it
seems to be just a group.
You know what I mean?
You can call it a religion,
but no one in that really is believe,
at least I don't think they are believing
the stories of Scientology the same
way that people are
believing that ridiculous.
I mean,
especially when it's written
by a science fiction author,
but because we know motor shit today,
you know,
it's like you can make some great
claims about some of these 10 past where
nobody knows shit.
Then it's,
you can spin a story that
nobody can disprove today.
Uh,
you know,
in three seconds people find out
all about you where they are like,
hey,
either the,
your profit,
the guy who was like ranting some
child porn the other day and he's like,
what are you talking about it?
So it's a little harder
to get away with stuff.
And you remember the uh,
Ted Haggard documentary that
Hbo and one of the things,
he goes to look for a job and
after he gets out and goes,
oh,
I think I'll be okay.
Unless they Google me,
I had said,
he said,
I think I'll be okay.
I'll get the job unless they Google me.
It's great.
It's Hilarious,
man.
That's hilarious.
He's back to teaching again.
He's got a church now.
Let your love it does guys are so
hardcore about morality and this and that.
And they thought that they
mellow out a little bit,
which would be healthy.
No,
they go all like,
I'll do methamphetamine
with the gay hooker.
That's one yard.
The wine was ugly in that
masturbation is the altity mets scene.
And it's like Jesus said haggard.
He blocked me on Twitter.
Yeah,
he did.
I made a joke.
He was talking about church
is like after church may be,
uh,
you know,
sandwiches and a picnic and then dot,
dot.
Dot.
And I wrote math and blowjob.
Yeah.
I mean,
but he's even by [inaudible].
Come on,
man.
You can't just,
we'll leave that out there.
He blocked me,
blocked me on Twitter.
The fuck.
I block people too,
but only when they're assholes.
If you say something that funny,
but you know,
some people that have got no sense of
humor priest to get busted with gay
hookers and math,
the rarely can they laugh at it.
No,
unfortunately.
Unfortunately.
Yeah.
So mostly the most unreal,
reasonable religion
would have to be Islam.
Right.
They're the most,
they if you don't,
I mean you can't make fun of them.
You can't,
today's pretty tough to do,
you know,
that woman that had to go into
hiding and they had changed her name.
Um,
she,
uh,
was a,
a calmness and she,
she wanted to have a drama
Hammad Monday and uh,
she had so many threats
against her life value.
Yeah.
They were really,
they will kill you.
Isn't that amazing?
It's amazing that that's tolerated.
Like that's some bullshit,
but yeah.
You need to fucking relax.
Yeah.
One thing that trips me out,
what is the reaction like when they
wear the Mohammad cartoons are nowhere,
even salamander actually back in the
day at branch of the Western world where
saying,
yeah,
sure,
de violence is bad.
The Muslim reaction by
release this terrible and the
fence if what these people
are doing.
And I'm just like,
are you kidding me?
You know,
you're giving into
burners and arguing that,
uh,
exactly what we want to squash,
freedom of opinion.
That's a,
in the name of respecting religion.
If you want to go to war,
if United States wants to go to war,
should go to war with anybody that wants
to kill a lady who suggests that you
should have a drama Hammad Monday,
that's who she had a war with.
Terrorism.
Go to war with them.
Have people that pretend
to do shit like that.
Find out who's ready to kill
them and then go get them.
Go get them boys.
You know those,
those,
the jackasses in the world.
Those are the people who you can't bounce
that bar that far back from where they
are.
They need to die and come back and live
life again and try to learn from this
life's experiences because there you're
not going to bounce back from being a
guy who is willing to cut the heart out
of a woman who wanted to have a drama
Hammad Monday you,
that guy's never going to be a
productive member of society.
He's not like,
oh,
I,
you know,
I don't sleep well at the restaurant.
Yeah,
that's a pretty big cut floor right there.
Yeah.
There's like a number,
like a,
a place where you go where you can't
bounce back when you're so much of a piece
of shit and so much of
a problem in society.
The camp,
I say child molesters,
I say anything,
anything along those murderers.
Like you can't bounce back
from that and you can't,
you gotta stop.
You gotta go.
We gotta Clean House and it's just like
you have to prune trees and you know,
like you have to shoot
horses have broken legs.
All right.
Right Brian?
Yes.
Fuck we talking about,
it's supposed to be about religion.
So did you,
you didn't learn anything doing this book,
you will learn something about the
reactions to people that when you praise
yourself,
controversy and even this conversation,
you know,
I'm sure there's going to be people,
you're lucky you don't have a Twitter.
See what is like,
do you have a Facebook?
Facebook?
Yeah.
Oh,
what is it?
What's your,
is it Danielle?
Billowing?
Yep.
I have a nice picture of
me holding my daughter.
Flipping people off.
Really?
Yeah.
Wow.
So you were preparing for
this response from the shelf?
Yeah.
Did you do that in a
response or you would like,
that was my ethical though the
last few months where I was like,
I've been through enough share to,
that's kind of my feeling
toward the university.
No one end,
I'm protective of the,
all the good theme there is.
And then,
yeah,
there I,
I'm like fuck you all.
Is your go to Karaoke Song?
I by Rem I chance no,
it's Pavarotti.
That's right.
You got that accent.
You might as well just bust
out some opera and go for it.
Right?
Is that you saying it over there?
Yeah.
Okay.
You're all right.
Don't hurt him.
Don't hurt yourself over there.
Um,
so your book,
when is it going to be out?
And I should be this week,
this week.
Keep giving me different dates.
I mean,
Amazon has it for like December 20,
but that hasn't always gets it wrong.
So I talked to the publisher and they
told me that she'll be out this week.
And it's Danielle Bolelli.
Yup.
How do you say it in Italian?
Daniella.
Balilla.
Yeah.
You can,
uh,
you can find him on Facebook if you want.
Look for the guy holding his daughter,
giving you the finger.
And,
um,
this has been fun,
man.
Really interesting conversation.
Thanks man.
Um,
and uh,
I hope people buy your book and uh,
we got to come back again.
We'll talk about some more shit.
I'm sure that's the beautiful
thing about religion.
There's hundreds and hundreds of hours
of discussion just on the silliness,
right.
May or drag anything.
Beautiful.
It's been a lot of fun,
man.
Thank you very much.
Thank you on here.
All right.
Uh,
that's it folks.
Thank you to the fleshlight
for sponsoring the podcast.
Thank you to um,
uh,
oh,
go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight
and enter in the code name Rogan and you
get 15% off and thanks to
a on@dotcomonnit.com for
sponsoring us as well.
The makers of Alpha brain,
the cognitive and enhancing
submit supplement.
I can't,
I should use some
talked to him once that
caffeine withdrawal.
It is probably,
I'm probably half retarded now.
The,
um,
uh,
the new stuff is new mood.
It's a five HTP and l
tryptofan supplement.
And we also have shroom tech,
a quarter steps mushroom
and B12 energy supplement.
That's fantastic for people who work
out really hard and I fucking love it.
I'm really getting into that stuff lately.
Um,
this Wednesday as in tomorrow we are
having a show here at the Ice House in
Pasadena.
What time's the show,
Brian?
I don't know.
I haven't figured it out yet.
We haven't figured it out.
That's how we roll bitches.
It's wild.
We're crazy.
But it will be a lot of cool guys.
Bert Kreischer is going to be on the show.
Bert Kreischer is also going to be on
the ice house chronicles podcast that we
do whenever we have a show
here at the ice house.
We,
during the time the guys are on
stage and before everyone's on stage,
we'll do a podcast
right here at this desk,
squad studio.
And so,
uh,
Christ will be on that.
And who knows how many other,
hopefully Joey Diaz is Joey and town.
I don't know.
Mad Flavor bitches.
What we'll have to bring Joe in and
we've been having some kickass shows.
They're amazing.
We had last one was Steevo bill burr.
Uh,
who else?
Ari Shaffir.
Joey Diaz,
Brendan Walsh,
me.
I mean we're,
we're,
these are like the craziest
shows you get and it's,
it's cheap.
It's,
what is it?
15 bucks.
Yep.
Yeah.
15 bucks.
And it's a real cool place
because it's intimate.
It's only 85 seats.
And we also have a show Friday every week.
Usually I'd per desk.
Why?
Where I take all like the other people,
like,
you know,
like Sam triply,
Jason Teebo at time and all those guys.
And I give them like,
they're their own separate show too.
So yeah,
solid solid shows.
If you're around and you
want to check those out,
I mean,
even if you don't know the guy's names,
[inaudible] guarantee you
if they're on the shows,
they're solid.
Um,
and um,
so this weekend the UFC,
oh,
who else we got?
We got Doug Stan Hall,
bitches Dunk.
Stan hope will be
joining us on a Thursday,
Thursday.
Doug's Stan hope is going to join us.
He's got a show Wednesday and Thursday.
Wednesday is at the Irvine Improv
and Thursdays at the Brayer Improv.
So we're going to bring
him down here on Thursday,
do a podcast with Doug,
get pissy drunk and then take them out to,
uh,
the Improv in Breyer that night.
So if you're looking to see him
go to the Irvine Improv's website,
just Google that shit,
son.
Go See Doug Stan hope on Wednesday at
Irvine and then Thursday and Breyer.
Doug will be here on a
Thursday for a podcast.
That's it.
It's fucking shows over.
Thank you.
Daniella.
Daniella,
Daniella [inaudible],
my friend.
You've,
uh,
brought us some very interesting
topics for conversation here.
And I'm gonna check out your
book and check out his new book.
50 things you're not supposed
to know about religion,
which should be out this week on info.com.
Disendow this sinful,
not info.com info.
They're much fucking liars.
Just Info Dotcom or telling you the truth.
Uh,
subscribe to death squad.
That's the only way on
[inaudible] subscribed to it.
Cause it's the only way you can
get the icehouse chronicles,
which I think is one of the
best podcasts out there.
It's,
it's,
it's all of us hanging out
pre shows and after shows.
And it's,
you get some hilarious shit out of it.
It's a lot of fun.
Everybody's getting amped up for the
show and there's a lot of shit talking.
And it's always fun when you got
like 10 comics in a room together.
The last one was beautiful.
It was Joey Diaz and Brendan Walsh,
and it was everybody.
And the one before with Yoshi.
I mean,
they're,
they're really fun.
All right.
The fucking shows over.
Love you bitches.
See Ya.
Bye.